conversation on facebook and twitter as
well
washington journal is next
[Music]
it's the washington journal for
september the 17th several senators
republicans and democrats alike are
calling for a postponement of a vote on
president trump's nominee to the supreme
court brett kavanaugh in light of his
accuser coming forward claiming he
allegedly sexually assaulted her years
ago we'll discuss how congress and the
white house could face that later in the
program speaking of the white house and
our first hour this morning an interview
with bob woodward the author of fear
trump in the white house
bob woodward thanks for joining us on
c-span thank you how would you
characterize from putting the all the
things that you put in the book together
the current functioning of the white
house
well as i say it's a nervous breakdown
other words the system is not working
there is not a team there is lots of
warfare
lots of
disagreement about some basic national
security obligations and some uh theory
of how the economy works i usually when
you get a white house together there's
this phrase team of rivals that comes
together does this apply to the white
house or is it a different
characterization in your mind as far as
the team is concerned well as uh reince
priebus the chief of staff for the first
six months in the white house says
that
trump fails the lincoln test it's not a
team of rivals but a team of predators
natural predators you describe it yes
yeah how would you describe who are
those predators on either side then
well um there are many sides but it's
every person for himself but the basic
approach in the book is to describe how
president trump makes decisions on
national security
and the economy the things that i think
really matter to people
and
there is just um to take
one scene a
national security council meeting
earlier this year in which the president
is still worrying about
all of the
expenditures
to have troops abroad particularly in
south korea 3.5 billion dollars though
we may get some money back uh nato
doesn't
you know thinks we're being ripped off
and
it is really
persisting after a year in office on
this idea
that uh we're being cheated we're being
played for suckers by
using our own money to defend other
countries
secretary of defense
mattis makes the point look this is the
best bargain we have we get
benefits to protect our country
and the president won't let go of it so
finally mattis says we're doing this to
prevent world war iii kind of jarring
declaration from the secretary of
defense to the president what was the
reaction from the president
uh he went on said you know why are we
doing this why are we spending money on
say taiwan
uh south korea he does not
understand this
old world order admittedly where we
thrive on trade relations the security
agreements
and the top secret uh
intelligence partnerships that we have
when you put this book together what do
you get in a sense of the core
philosophies of the president what does
he hold on to and why is that
well he has a couple of ideas
one that trade deficits somehow are bad
and take money from americans
99.9
of the economist would say that's just
not so actually it helps the economy
because
and it sounds kind of technical but it's
not but americans are buying
goods abroad because they're better
quality or cheaper
therefore americans have more money to
buy other things or to to save president
thinks we're losing this money
and that it's bad policy
and
he stands alone with two of his aides
and
persists in this and
it
it's alarming to
economists and
policy makers on the left the right
democrats republicans because
it um
it's just not true
and if they have if he has these core
philosophies then who in the white house
either previous or pre uh present helped
shape those who are the biggest drivers
of that who really shaped and sharpened
where he's standing today the the point
is he shapes it himself he
there's one scene in the book where they
he's asked where do you get these ideas
that i've had them for 30 years and
says if you disagree with me you're
you're wrong
and then gary cohn i think
said that and asked him the question
like where do you get these ideas or how
did you come up with
he was the chief economic policy uh
director of the national economic
council in the white house
and then i think the president's
response was i just have these
philosophers i'm character or
paraphrasing there but what was the
president's specific reaction to that
look i've had you know these this is the
way i look at the world and uh
don't waste your time in a sense
talking to me about it well
presidents heads of any organization uh
are in part measured by how much they
grow and learn
and trump's inclination is to not learn
and change his mind
you have to change your mind you have to
listen
uh but there's a hesitancy that's what
you're saying yeah it's not a hesitancy
is it is a declaration this is the way
it is because you talk about and we can
talk about further in the book they take
them to the pentagon they try to talk
about the cert various forces in the
world how the world works in the sense
and the reaction is a negative one right
and look he's a disrupter he came in to
change things but when you are a change
agent
you inherit the past and you can't just
if you're moving into a house you can't
burn it down you have to okay let's
redesign let's renovate let's change
things but he wants to
discard these things that are
foundations
of our national security and uh
the global economic policy and he
doesn't like globalists and he says
you're to a number of people you're an
fa globalist
bob woodward joining us for the hour
here to talk about his book fear trump
in the white house if you want to ask
him questions 202 748 8 000 for
democrats 202 748 8001 for republicans
independence 202 748 8002 you talked
about the sourcing in the book calling
it deep background how does that work
out practically in your writing of the
book well it means that i'm going to
protect the sources and
the nice luxury of having time to do
this you can talk to people go back to
them again if after you get more
information get notes get meeting notes
get documents and so there is a
kind of deep reporting
to everything in the book
uh there's a passage there this is a
dialogue with henry mcmaster and it goes
as such saying about after about five
minutes he interrupted you use quotes
here i've been hearing about this
nonsense for about afghanistan for 17
years with no success close quote he
said before mcmaster finished playing
one of the issues you go on to say we've
got a bunch of inconsistent short-term
strategies we can't continue with the
same old strategy that's not in quotes
but can you talk about how
how you constructed that and how you
used your various sources to do that
some of these are nsc meetings and
they're note takers and other people
take notes and you go to people and oh
yes i remember
exactly what was said in a courtroom
somebody can take the stand and say
look i remember
exact language and that's accepted
in courtrooms and
by
triangulating
you can get a
pretty exact picture of what's going on
and of course on
afgh afghanistan a lot of people think
the president's
right we've been in that war for 17
years doesn't look like it's going to
get better and the
pentagon wanted to add thousands of
troops
he was very resistant
uh at one point
secretary of defense mattis uh just said
to him we need to know whether the
commander-in-chief
is with us we cannot continue
to fight a half-assed war
when it comes to sourcing this is what
colombia journalism reviews pete vernon
said about the book he said this quote
woodward's approach hasn't changed the
climate in which his sources are viewed
has every administration is filled with
people who have an agenda we want to
spend events in their favor but the
lines of credibility have shifted in
taking on the trump presidency as his
topic woodward is left to assemble a
reliable book from unreliable sources
well yeah i mean he he's wrong i mean
the there it's a reliable book from
reliable sources and
there are
people and there are
documents and i quote from documents at
length and
so it's
carefully meticulously done as i said i
had time to work on this i did not have
to do daily stories
are you the sole person when you're
cross-referencing sources and material
to make sure it's accuracy or accurate
or are there other people involved in
the process with you
that's an important question i have an
assistant evelyn duffy who
transcribes all the tapes
and there are hundreds of hours of tapes
and
we will go through it and make sure that
we've represented from the documents and
notes and interviews
what we call the best obtainable version
of the truth and she
is
dogged and say well no wait a minute
this is the word or let's clarify here
uh let's let's
be uh
as meticulous as you can and uh it's a
great asset and i
thank her at the beginning of the book
evelyn
somebody who
in spirit and
commitment was effectively the co-author
of this book we have calls lined up for
you so we will start we will start in
plano texas with chris independent line
you're on with bob woodward good morning
go ahead
good morning mr woodward about
two-thirds of the way through your book
and i'm enjoying it very much it's very
vivid and it paints a really great
picture of the white house i had a
question i hate using the word but i had
a question about collusion namely that a
number of conservative columnists have
been
saying that your book's absence of
discussion of collusion
is somehow exculpatory and i just wanted
to know what your position was and all
things on that matter or if the book was
even intended to cover that ankle
well if it's covered in uh in a way
what i've said is i found no new
evidence of collusion
there is some out there on the record
publicly some of the reporting done by
my own newspaper the washington post the
new york times
but
i found
no new evidence
but that doesn't mean it doesn't exist
in fact
president trump's a lawyer for 18 months
john dowd concluded
that mueller had something that he was
not telling
john dowd about in the meetings that
dowd had
with mueller
the other point on this i think and it's
critical
the real answer to collusion
is in russia and uh
as a reporter if i went there i
almost certainly would not come back
you can't operate in russia
united states intelligence agencies do
and they produce that initial report
concluding
that russia
was meddling in the 2016 presidential
election
it's going to be very interesting to see
if
those intelligence agencies or the
special counsel mueller come up with
anything
that's intelligence based
from
russia but that's where the real
key answer is going to come from i
believe we have a viewer off of twitter
who asks you in relation to that saying
does mr woodward think that muller or
some other entity of the department of
justice will subpoena his notes and
recordings mine no why why would they do
that in relation to what you wrote about
the mueller investigation perhaps well
but
let's hope that doesn't happen i
obviously hope it doesn't happen and i
expect it not to happen
simply because i deal with lots of very
sensitive national security
issues and debates
i've done this for now 47 years and in
nine presidencies
and
try to provide as much information in
the book
but
not going so far is to disclose sources
and methods uh to
harm
operations essential to the security of
this country or that might get somebody
killed or some source
blown so there is
a line
i tend to push it i think the public
needs to know more
rather than less there are people in the
government who would disagree with that
but i know
many times i've
been careful and people
who know about these intelligence
operations
understand that
so that will there ever be a time when
we hear the source taping or otherwise
from this book yeah what
my general approach is uh after
30 40 years like in the case of
watergate carl bernstein and i
our papers are at the university of
texas all the notes all the drafts
everything
from
that watergate investigation we
conducted except from people who are
still alive and then once they're
deceased those papers get turned over
and are made public so
at some point
somebody's going to be able to go
through
all of this and
see exactly where it came from and and
see that the
rigorousness of the process did you talk
to mr bernstein about the book and did
he help shape it in any way yeah carl
and i talk all the time and uh
he did he he was he had all kinds of
ideas he's working for
uh cnn
and he has done a lot of uh his own
reporting and we would talk back and
forth about where this is
where it's going what the outcome might
be
my general approach is
reporting on the future is
futile because you don't know what's
going to happen and in this case
there's
an
ending
the president's lawyer john
dowd concluding that
the president is a effing liar
uh
my newspaper has
i've i think uh established that there
are four thousand two hundred plus
matters that the president has said that
are false or
misrepresent what uh what occurred
but on
the outcome of the mueller investigation
or the trump presidency this is
a i believe a slice of reality
of covering the period
actually during the campaign a little
bit uh up through the first 15 months of
his time in office let's go to minnesota
democrats line this is bob go ahead
morning
thanks for taking my call
i've got a couple of questions
one of my biggest concerns is that
trump seems to be anti-media
and
notice wondering if you think that
he is
if we're in danger of being taken over
by a dictatorship
uh
i
certainly hope not
yes
the president is anti-media says the
media is the enemy of the people
has coined this term fake news
which
a lot of people
particularly a lot of trump supporters
agree with that i think the
only answer for us
in the media is to do more reporting be
careful about the tone
there should not be
a smugness and a self-satisfaction
uh in the writing or
when reporters or
commentators appear on television but uh
we we still have
democracy we still have a first
amendment
and uh
let let's hope
that you know it that will continue uh
trump
talks tough on a lot of these matters
and uh
i you you see the
news media generally not pulling punches
you write about in the book how reince
priebus would shape his schedule in
order to keep them from certain media
input could you expand on that
yeah what the chief of staff uh called
uh
trump's bedroom where he did a lot of
his tweeting the devil's workshop
and
special times when
the president would be engaged in
tweeting or preparing tweets the
witching hour and would try to work the
schedule so he would be coming back to
the white house
for example
late at on sunday night after the
weekend because he normally goes away
to one of his golf resorts for the
weekend or goes out
for rallies or other events and so
that the president would come back after
nine o'clock when cable news is kind of
doing softer programming most of the
time and you also write about the
creation at one time of a tweet
committee for the president but
something that never took to fruition
yeah the
number of the aides said you know why
don't we
review the tweets why don't we
fact check them and so forth and uh that
didn't work out the president uh runs
his own twitter account uh this is from
washington state independent line willie
hello
good morning good morning
hello bob uh i uh lord knows i love the
country and i wouldn't have
put this information out there
uh the way you've done it uh
it seems to be uh
subversive
the press is just
you have to
excuse me
no i didn't say anything go ahead sir
well i wouldn't have i loved the country
bob and i i just wouldn't have put this
information out there the the people who
are our enemies are listening to this
and
it's just
appalling that we don't have the
sophistication to realize that the
invisible hand is at work here
and the
they're not going to be appearing as
russians or or in jack boots or anything
like that they're going to be
dressed just as you are
uh trying to infiltrate the government
uh
hamper the government and it's just
this is how they operate okay can i
answer that first of all we i remember
during the watergate case and nixon a
lot of people said well we can't stand
to know the truth actually we need to
know the truth and there's no way
that i can take a position
as a journalist or as an author hey
let's
camouflage this let's uh somehow
hold back uh the democracy we have is
strong because
we try to base it
and the base the debate on facts and
whatever is going on
foreigners of trying to subvert the
government
you know we have fbi and
a massive intelligence agencies who
monitor uh what what's going on in in
fact after 9 11
the whole
intelligence
establishment
blossomed and uh
tens of billions of dollars each year
spent on this uh so
as you know we haven't had a for for
example
a major terrorist attack
in this country since uh 9 11. so i just
think that's my job uh i i don't think
uh we should
somehow pretend
uh
gee th
this gets to the emperor
has no clothes and
you've got to
describe
what's going on i think that makes the
country stronger not weaker from
california david and corona hello
how are you good morning good morning mr
woodward i um
i have no doubt that you're based on
your track record that uh the book has
uh factual and you're giving us uh
a true picture of what's going on
my question is at some point in the
future
trump will no longer be president it'll
either be
he'll lose or it'll be the completion of
a second term but whatever it is
when he leaves the problem doesn't go
away because the division remains
in your
estimation what how do we get back
together as a country
and at least
in a civil way
address problems and and reason things
out together uh
great question
i i'm just the the reporter and
the political system we have whatever
strengths or weaknesses it might have is
going to have to deal with that and uh
obviously the political system is being
tested you're exactly right about the
divisions uh it there is a polarization
that
has not existed before
the remedy if and there will be a remedy
i have to
be an optimist or i am an optimist
in fact
has to do
with people listening people uh
dealing and agreeing
on what the facts are
and uh
you know we may have
because this has happened before we may
have a crisis in this country where
president trump's going to have to
manage
the unexpected
and
that is
going to test him and the country uh
and
even
in a sense the day-to-day
tests everything and so
let
let them
figure out how to do it
my
approach is
to
try to answer the question what really
happened who are these people if you
look through
the book read it you you will
see who trump is i believe what
motivates him what he cares about what
he doesn't care about and it's a
almost a total universe universe
portrait of him in the operation of the
white house that's where my energy
goes uh not getting into uh
your very good question and that's a
great question
uh for the elected representatives that
we have uh a viewer on twitter says
where did you begin and were in other
words did you start by inquiring about
the overall climate and decision-making
process of the white house or did it
relate to a specific incident
related to all specific incidents in
talking to people and say what
what did you see what do you hear what
did you know on the key issues in the
book covers foreign policy what happened
north korea what happened in the
afghanistan debate the middle east
debates how did
the president decide to impose tariffs
on china or steel tariffs how did the
tax plan
get formulated
what are
the debate on trade and immigration and
so forth and
there are people there who are
specialists or
key people in the white house or in the
way
in the west wing or
in the
departments the cabinet offices
and
you can
what what's what's so interesting in
doing something like this is
you can go to someone and if you win
their trust
uh
you can say what happened that's
important
what
and they immediately know
and you that is your jumping off point
what's important what has
uh impact
uh what is
the nature of the relationship
that the president has with his key
aides key cabinet officers uh but one of
those interesting relationships senator
lindsey graham apparently and
particularly when it comes to foreign
policy what was the influence of why did
he have such a large influence
well he's close to trump they play golf
a lot and
lindsey graham is in a sense a greek
chorus of one in the book because he
talks to trump a lot they deal on
domestic issues they deal on foreign
policy issues
senator graham the republican from south
carolina is a hawk
on military issues
very much
believes we need to do
something
on the
something humanitarian on the issues uh
for instance uh in immigration
uh from tennessee democrats lying and
you're next for our guest go ahead
thank you for taking my call this
morning
um mr woodward i have a very very
deep-hearted compliment to pay you
i find this book utterly fascinating and
it gives me hope
i don't know how to explain this i'm a
never trumper
i am anti-trump i everything about him
um
just turns me off
and in reading your book
i have to pay you the deepest compliment
in that you have changed my mind
about
uh
you you have given me hope that that
there is
that that there that there are two sides
to this
i have changed my mind concerning one
aspect of mr trump
and i owe that directly to you
what was that aspect
um
when i read
your description
and in-depth detail of the meeting
i believe that it was a meeting
before
he was inaugurated president
and the um intelligence community
figures
people went in and explained to him the
situation
with
the russian
tampering
and in that
you described
um mr comey's
the way mr comey handled that meeting
i i was never
a mr comey fan as you can figure out
but when i read
your complete
definition and description of what mr
trump
must have been feeling
during that meeting
i saw his side
and i saw
something that that literally changed my
mind
that's a fair point uh
what i'd say is that comey then the fbi
director took a summary of this
steele dossier that made
some allegations
about the president
and
what he had done allegedly
unproven with prostitutes in moscow in
2013
and my point
was
why would you present this to the
president
at this time
uh
two weeks away from being inaugurated
and it it's it's got the aroma of the j
edgar hoover fbi hey look
this dirt we've got on you
and i know in other presidencies
that i've reported on when there was
this transition
period
new president was coming in often
allegations were made particularly about
president clinton before he took office
and
the response was to
take the allegations and and not
confront the president president-elect
with them but to
throw them in the burn bag
knowing that if there was something to
it
it would come out and of course this was
the
white water investigation the lewinsky
matter and so forth not that that
started earlier but that there was a
pattern here
and
the
fbi's one of these incredibly powerful
institutions if they decide
to go after you and investigate you
they can look at anything
finances personal
relationships businesses
all of the
people
who are in your orbit and so forth so
it's a it's a power that's got to be
used very very carefully and in this
case i felt
uh there was not the care taken
particularly i mean they know who trump
was volatile i mean even report in the
book
that he told president trump after this
told his lawyer
this is something millennia should not
hear about
so
i agree with you that's a moment where i
thought
uh trump
what where they got in
his face on some of these things
that created
a very intense suspicion between the
president and the fbi republican lying
from arlington virginia mary hi
yes hi good morning um i just wanted to
get your response to a comment that i
heard
from cheryl atkinson over the weekend
and she said that in general and
specifically regarding your book that
certain journalistic practices aren't
being adhered to
for example the over-reliance on
anonymous sources
she said that anonymous sources should
be used
very sparingly and with as great as
specificity as possible
and it seems like there's a lot of
anonymous sources in your book and just
in general in in reporting and the other
thing she said was that when you report
on someone you usually
you know interview that person to get
their
their view or their take on what what
was said about them and um in terms of
this book you reported on the president
but you actually didn't interview the
president and then finally um
there were disparaging comments that
were made by various people dowd
mattis kelly
and i was wondering um if they said
those things directly to you
and if not because they're denying they
said them and
mary thank you for that three points
there so we'll let our guests address
them okay first of all the
sources are not anonymous to me i know
who they are and
this is about specific incidents
that the sources witnessed or
participated in and
on the issue of uh and
by having the time and checking things
and and there's there's not a vagueness
to it it's 2pm on tuesday july 15th they
gathered in this office
this is what people said this is what
the president said this is what the
president
did
i asked
six people
to interview president trump
i
he
no one ever said oh yeah he's willing to
i broke my spear on it
the president called me
last month
and
president trump did and said
why didn't we have this interview and i
said because he said
he wanted to do it and that i'd always
treated him fairly i listed people i'd
talked to
and president trump acknowledged in one
case and kellyanne conway who was in the
the room he said why didn't you tell me
because i went spent a long time with
kellyanne conway going through what i
wanted to ask the president about
and
it's either the president or some aides
decided he should not talk to me or
the there was this breakdown as i call
it a nervous breakdown in the white
house where information uh is not
getting to him so there was
maximum
effort
to
try to go over these things with him
because it he is really the the focus of
the book and
you use unnamed sources in my business
because
if you go to people get out a microphone
and say this is on the record you're
going to get the press release version
of reality
if you establish a relationship of trust
and
say i want to know what's real
people are not going to talk
and tell you things with their name
behind it but i have to be very careful
and so i test everything that i get
and
if you look through the book you'd see
verbatim quotes these notes the these
quotes come
from people who
are writing them down
all kinds of documents
very specific
scenes so
do you want the press release version of
what happened
in the white house which unfortunately
and as i have said before the president
is conducting a war on truth he just
will not accept the truth on lots of
matters and
in that environment
if you
talk to people on the record
you're gonna get bs
and so the job is to
dig
as deeply as you can this is the ninth
president
i've done books in reporting for the
washington post on and the the method
uh is well
tested and very meticulous uh to the
point one of the points she was making
we have a viewer on twitter says then
why would jim mattis rex tillerson uh mr
cohen gary cohn and others dispute
observations well they're not just
there's what's called the politically
calculated
survival denial
where
a
number of people have said oh well this
doesn't capture everything people have
disputed
uh some specific things but there but
not all kinds of other things and so
look people need to survive
going back to the nixon case we used to
call this the non-denial denial it
appears to be a denial
and
in fact
it is not so that's that's part of
how people survive in the administration
that's part of
just the reality of
these survival denials and
take them for what they are believe me
not much
and uh not
the kind of
vague comments by some people well it
doesn't it's
it's selective yes everything is
selective
and it doesn't totally reflect
someone's experience in the white house
i think it
i know it accurately reflects it
does
you know it
perfectly
on every moment uh you know that
that is impossible so i
my feeling is there's been
uh some comments by people is of
great actually greater confidence in the
method i use for bob woodward this is
alan in little rock arkansas
uh good grief you sure answer questions
taking a lot of time but let me just say
i love c-span love listening
surely mr woodward knows it's a cross
section a great cross section of america
every day and he's putting himself up
for some open questions to the american
people for a change
but i've got two or three quick
criticisms and then two quick questions
one is i hope you didn't take that
lady's compliment from tennis
from tennessee as a compliment
because she's referring to that
dossier which was what the corrupt fbi
leadership used to
open up this false probe against the
president but you didn't explain that
and then you said
this repeated comment all the time that
the president said the media is the
enemy of the american people which he
did not say which you could have
corrected he said the fake news the
false stories the bias is the enemy
which it is
but then the third thing is and uh what
came to mind before i called today was
just this despicable choice that you
took to introduce your book on 9 11 of
all days of the year you took that day
and i think if there were to be a
photo caricature of a charlatan your
face would be on it but here's two quick
questions
okay now i you've made it very clear uh
how you approach these things uh the
president has said the news media is the
enemy
of the people not fake news he does call
uh
various news organizations uh fake news
and uh you know the publication date of
this book is decided uh
by
the the publisher and it's a sequence to
get it out in the fall and
uh i'm not sure what your point is your
questions alan quickly good questions is
we know the there was a corruption of
the fbi that fed you all those stories
during watergate this so-called deep
throat we know that was an fbi agent so
i'd like to tell everybody how many of
these anonymous sources that you're
using in your book
are from fbi sources
and then the other question i've had all
these years sir okay let me answer one
at a time
first of all all the information
in the reporting on watergate has been
substantiated
the president resigned we had all kinds
of sources which
are identified in the book carl
bernstein and i did called all the
president's men
and uh
you know you're just wrong on that sir
good question is i thought it was
interesting that the watergate burglars
that no one ever talks about the cuban
fbi burglars that were caught in the
watergate hotel were the same crew
under
g gordon liddy
that were in the bay of pigs invasion
would you explain anything okay
okay
look i
stand by that in history in the nixon
tapes established what happened uh in
watergate uh you know who the sources
are
uh in the trump book uh you know that's
gonna come out someday and uh is all
kinds of people uh in fact somebody in a
key position after the book came out
who's in office now called me and said
everyone knows what you have in this
book
is 1 000
correct
that that
this is
the reality
and uh it's
my view
i think people need to wake up to
reality and not deal in some
conspiracy theory that the fbi
is behind all of this
the the people
behind my reporting
uh work or worked for the president uh
from arizona phoenix arizona democrat
slime bob hello
yes good morning and thank you for speak
c-span and thank you for having uh mr
woodward on
uh this is a call of thank you
and uh
i give
bob five stars for accurate reporting
i'm about a third of the way through the
book and i feel like i'm reading a
confidential report that i should not be
reading i've been a fan for four and a
half decades
i've read all of your watergate stuff i
loved it i've read most of the things
you've written about your nine
presidents and i gave you a plus and
that's all i have to say thank you
okay thank you uh independent line
michael
from washington state good morning
good morning uh hi mr woodward thanks
very much for your many years of service
to our country and the world
um
i would like to ask if uh well two quick
questions please
um if you believe that uh a fifth or
sixth grader a person of a fifth or
sixth grader mentality would be able to
beat hillary clinton in multiple debates
and also
what is it that you believe has happened
to investigative journalism
because there doesn't seem to be a whole
lot of it going on anymore
and i'm wondering if you believe as i do
that it seemed to stop right after 9 11.
i i think there's been a lot of very
good uh investigative reporting the the
question about a fifth or sixth grader i
quote secretary of defense mattis
telling associates that president trump
acts like and has the understanding of
quote a fifth or 6th grader
this is
documented and the
the reasons for that conclusion are laid
out
in the book
interesting question of whether
president or donald trump beat hillary
in those debates lots of people think he
did some think he didn't
but
the important point is he won the
election
and so what i'm trying to do
is describe what he does
as president and as i've said go into
all the areas that really affect
people's lives in
foreign policy and domestic economic
policy
republican line north carolina karen
hello
hi
first of all i was a lifelong democrat
that voted for barack obama twice and i
ran like a scalded dog to the republican
party because the democrats are openly
bigoted against white people now but the
only re the only way i'd ever buy your
book is if i was going to send it to
venezuela to help them with their toilet
paper shortage but the thing that's
really killing me about you bob is that
you don't even uh you're not even aware
enough to know that you have the obama
trudeau globalist uh language uh virus
you are working gagging sounds into your
speech patterns bob why are you doing
that okay karen thanks okay well we know
what she thinks and uh that's what's
great about
c-span doing this and you you
hear and people can
judge the merits of
what is said uh jim off of twitter asked
about process saying how do we know
what quoted passages are real and which
ones you quote reconstructed and put in
quotes well they're all real there's
nothing reconstructed about it you
get notes documents you actually
interview people who are there and
get their
memory and some of these things were
done
very quickly after
the event after the meeting after the
decision uh discussion uh in the white
house
and
it's
so carefully done
uh and and
you know that's that's what i found it
so one of the other callers
said it's kind of like looking at
a report that
somebody would do on
a business where the board of directors
called somebody in and said okay
interview everyone look at everything
and find out what happened
i
would essentially say that's what this
book is
uh from massachusetts independent line
robert hi
hi good morning and um i just want to
say thank you for the book because
what i'm saying that
look at all the people who are toilet
paper i mean we come to a point that
people want to let the country go into
uh you know hail in a hand basket we
have a president that
demonstrated
he's a wheeling agent and create you
know people willing to jump on a uh
a pranks you know our ensuite with trump
and destroy the country we do have kids
to raise and i thank you
for the book and have the courage to uh
bring
uh uh the truth to us because he's not
the united states he only worked for the
united states and people don't
understand that you know
the guy is not prepared for the
presidency and the people that are
defending him
they uh
the uh to me the enemy of the truth the
guy demonstrated disease lie even
deny that the tape on the uh hollywood
tape might not be him when he uh agreed
it was him i mean what else do the
people want in in it to me it's like
to tell the truth uh on your part and i
give you great credit because the
country right now is so divided and
hillary in that you have a question sir
yeah
yeah well the question is i
i'm asking
what do you think that
the president
should
do
to
what we should do to have the president
respect the rule of law in this country
because caller thank you apologies for
that
okay um
that's uh that's an important question
and uh there are debates about the
things he does
there is the mueller investigation
which is ongoing
they've
achieved
guilty pleas or convictions of lots of
people on
issues
related or marginally related to the
focus of the investigation
did someone did president trump or
somebody in his
campaign or
in his government collude with russia
on during the 2016 election that
question has not been answered yet
and
we're going to get a report or some
finding sometime
by uh
by special counsel mueller and
i
i
looked at some of this and i think there
are not conclusive
at least
pieces of evidence that i could find one
way or the other when you talk about the
mueller investigation you talk about
john dowd and particularly how willing
he was to offer up information to the
investigation can you characterize the
length he went to it is what he offered
well john dowd
his theory of the case was let's
cooperate with mueller because there's
nothing the president has to hide
and so they turned over
the data
provided 37 witnesses in the campaign
and from the white house
1.4 million pages of documents from the
campaign 20 000
pages of documents from the white house
dowd thought this would speed up the
investigation and mueller would declare
it over
and
the president
not necessarily
that there would be no evidence that the
president did anything wrong in this uh
at the end as i report in the book
john dowd concluded that mueller
seemed to have something that there was
something
he was not telling
the president's lawyer john dowd about
and
dowd concluded that the president's
suspicion about mueller
voiced publicly and privately the witch
hunt uh
that the suspicion uh was correct and
that mueller had
played
doubt for a sucker
the president for a sucker and got all
of this evidence and then was not being
uh forthcoming was kept pressing for
some sort of
uh
session under oath with the president
which dowd insisted
after practicing with the president
quite simply the president not capable
of telling the truth
and when the president said he was going
to testify dowd resigned they're very
human
phone calls between dowd and the
president on this and dowd regretting
very much that he has to resign but he
said i cannot sit
next to you as your lawyer and let you
testify you are incapable of testifying
and telling the truth a very
severe
conclusion
and
one
let's
face it
look at the president's
statements time and time again that are
just not supported by fact pittsburgh
pennsylvania democrat slime patrick
hello
you know it's stunning axios came out
with a poll
regarding the american contrived press
and uh mr which mr woodward is part of
in this cabal
and the
the system is identified by the american
people as 85 percent of the american
people believe that the mainstream media
produces fake news which they do uh my
friend who lived through the soviet
union said listening to the american uh
media system corporatized media is
literally
like listening to soviet news agencies
and
caller we're short on time so directly
to your question or comment please well
my my question and comment is mr
woodward why don't you support the
implementation the fairness doctrine if
you have nothing to hide about the cabal
that is destroying the democracy and the
first amendment by the american people
then you should be in support of the uh
the fairness doctrine and media which
will give the american people a voice
instead of destroying social media
networks and and equating every american
with conspiring with okay sir i i
personally practice the fairness
doctrine and try to get as much
information uh that i can
and
as i as i say i'll repeat myself it's
very very carefully done this is
i've done this
for 47 years i don't
carry
uh
politics into it i've been accused of
being a leftist of being a conservative
of being
this or that
somebody president trump accused me of
being a democratic operative
uh ask hillary clinton about that in
some of the
things i have written about her and her
husband uh in books uh it's it's absurd
somebody
the other
some time ago called me
a uh
a radical centrist
and uh i think that's probably
uh where i come from uh it's what
happened can you verify it and
present it and that's
that's what i tried to do how many of
your previous books on white house has
taken the same deep background approach
that you took with this book
all of them uh
that uh what i
do is
going back to nixon all you know
ford
carter reagan
the bushes obama
uh
spend time to
get information that will be
that i can verify from
other sources it is a
consistent approach
what's interesting when a book will come
out people will
like henry kissinger on nixon
what was fascinating
excuse me carl bernstein and i wrote
about
a very emotional scene on the eve of
nixon's resignation where
nixon and kissinger got down and prayed
and the president really kind of lost it
and was pounding the carpet and when
that was published
kissinger came out and denied it and
then years later when his own memoir was
published he described exactly
the same scene
and
said to people
that
president nixon was almost a basket case
so
as ben bradley the editor of the post
said the truth emerges sometimes
it takes only a day or two sometimes it
takes years i don't know if you've
talked about this in the book other
places but you talked about the
president's relationship with melania
trump how would you characterize that
well i just have a couple of scenes
milani
focuses very much on
their son
and
that's
you know that's exactly one of the
things she should do but i i didn't get
into the nature of the relationship
very much a
number of people are quoted in the white
house saying she has a lot of influence
and i think steve bannon refers to her
as the hammer that she's very tough
uh from our republican line texas this
is james
james in texas go ahead you're on
yes please uh
i regard your work
is
not scientific
it's uh personal communication
and it's anecdotal
and the general press is the same way
they do not publish
any sample size
they do not publish any probability
they do not publish any coefficient of
variants
so that no one can call the studies
and the multiple polls
is partial
okay
reporting
is not pure science but there is a
method of talking to people and getting
records and documents and notes and
files
and
tell people what you found what carl
bernstein and i have always called the
best obtainable version of the truth
and
that's what's presented in this book uh
from georgia durr hello
well good morning gentlemen i just
walked in my door on sorry ago i didn't
hear the conversation before now but i
just had to pick up my phone when i
heard somebody denigrating our president
uh obama do we all remember about how
this fat cat republican says our mission
is to see to it that this guy doesn't
get re-elected and there was everything
a man tried to do uh but i wanted to
call sir and thank you for your work and
uh i just want to ask all what is how
happy is everybody that they have
inspired all this enmity a bunch amongst
the citizenry you walk around the
country and the city and my
i'm in my 71st year and people don't say
hello to each other nobody likes each
other how are all these new from farmers
to our country hopefully
gonna be able to participate in the
defense of our country got to call it
gotcha thanks
uh i'm not sure what the question was
there or if there was one we'll go to
maryland then gloria hello
good morning um
mr woodward you're the reason why i
called i don't know enough god bless you
to bestow
in your behalf thank you for your
service
i prayed for you when you were
grievously wounded while being embedded
on
foreign soil and we owe you a great deal
because the truth
is a catalyst that we all need i want to
encourage america
to
continue to stay wedded to the fact that
this government of the people by the
people and for the people shall not
perish from the earth and that we will
continue to form a more perfect union
we will
become one nation under god indivisible
in spite of the madness and insanity
that is going on in the white house
recognize some of that language just in
fairness i was not i was not wounded uh
you you're mixing me up with bob
woodruff
from abc the reporter who was uh indeed
wounded but i was not i served in the
navy for five years
after i got out of college
from dorothy
virginia hello go ahead
oh okay um
this is my first time calling good
morning to uh
you um this is my first time calling
ever
but i just wanted to make a brief
comment
about um
what's going on
for one thing i was
i did not vote for president trump
i voted for hillary
and
the minute i came out of the booth
from
voting for hillary
um
oh no i gotta
uh
it just said i didn't i felt that i did
i shouldn't have done that and i said
lord
i repent i'm sorry i voted for hillary
because what and then i but now i know
why
i got that feeling and that
it so dorothy not not to cut you short
only because our guest is here to talk
about his book do you have a question
about that
well the thing the thing is about what
i'm saying is that i voted for president
trump
and i'm glad i voted for him
because i feel that he's doing an
excellent job
and i can't see why people can't see
that
that he's done it it's a lot of it i
wish people would get on it and talk
about what not only president trump but
other people that did or you know
to other people that they are talking
about
to dorothy thank you okay
um
you know the i think this is a case
where the the book and the information
and it speaks for itself what kind of
when you get responses to this not only
from president trump himself via twitter
but what's been the responses of
particularly critics of of the book via
twitter or other social media what's it
been like for you
to a certain extent it reflects a
polarization in the country but i also
think
the simple fact is lots of people know
i've done this
uh almost for five decades now and
that the
reporting
uh in every case has stood the test of
time and winds up
as i said sometimes very quickly and
sometimes it takes a long time to
be verified and uh it's some it's
something that's done
uh
with no
uh political perspective or animus or if
people have pointed out here there's
some things in the book
that show
president trump
strong and
as
a victim at times it also shows
that he's conducting a war on truth and
does not understand some of the
fundamental
economic and national security issues uh
fear trump in the white house authored
by bob woodward who joins us for this
conversation mr woodward thanks for your
time thank you nice being here for the
next half hour we're going to discuss
the latest revelations about the
president's nominee for the supreme
court brett kavanaugh several people on
capitol hill senators democratic and
republican calling for the postponement
of a vote on judge kavanaugh because of
recent allegations of alleged sexual
harassment if you want to talk about
that democrats 202 748 000 republicans
202 sum for eight eight thousand one
independence 202. seven four eight eight
thousand two we'll take those when we
come back
[Music]
[Applause]
they're to gain access to their
citizenship rights watch this weekend on
c-span 2's book tv
good evening
good evening i'm bradley graham the
co-owner of politics and prose along
with my wife lisa muscatine and on
behalf of everybody at politics and
prose and the staff here at george
washington university welcome thank you
thank you very much for coming
you know we we at politics and prose
have been working with the folks here at
lisner for a number of years now and um
putting on large events like like the
one this evening and we're very very
grateful to be able to have access to
such a spacious and convenient facility
right here in uh in the center of
washington
well it's
certainly been a a day of of high drama
we've had
all too many dramatic days over the past
couple of years but as history looks
back today's senate judiciary committee
hearing
will no doubt stand out as a truly
extraordinary event
if you're like me
many of you are still processing the
testimony of dr ford and judge kavanaugh
and certainly our featured author this
evening bob woodward will have some of
his own thoughts to share
about the kavanaugh nomination in the
context of the trump presidency
which his new book fear portrays in such
devastating detail
bob has been observing and reporting on
major developments in washington for
nearly half a century
working for the washington post he's
covered nine presidents
he has shared in two pulitzer prizes
first for the post coverage of the
watergate scandal and second in 2003 as
the lead reporter for coverage of the 9
11 attacks
fear is bob's 19th book all have been
national bestsellers
and fear marks bob's 13th book at the
top of the bestseller list
i think he holds the record for the most
number one non-fiction bestsellers of
any author
now each time one of his revelatory
books appears
the question comes up
how does he get people to talk to him
why do people agree to share their
stories with them
i suppose everyone who confides in bob
has his or her own reason
but one thing i know
as a former colleague of his at the
washington post who has on occasion
reported in bob's wake one thing i know
is how hard bob prepares
and how hard he pushes and probes
he's methodical and relentless
fastidious about facts
and hell bent on obtaining documents
whenever he can get his hands on them
to verify whether something did or
didn't happen
let me just say too
again as a former colleague of bob's
that bob can be truly generous with his
time and his advice
many of us at the post have been
grateful he's remained on the staff
as an associate editor contributing to
the paper and coaching other reporters
when he could have chosen a number of
other career paths
bob will be in conversation here this
evening with another first-rate
journalist michael schmidt
michael's with the new york times and he
and he started there as a news clerk 13
years ago and now covers national
security and federal law enforcement
he was part of two teams that won
pulitzer prizes this year one for
reporting on workplace sexual harassment
issues and the other for coverage of
russia's interference in the 2016
presidential election
and russia's connection to the trump
campaign
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming both bob and michael
[Applause]
it's the nicest anyone's been and
certainly to me in a long time even
though they're cheering for you
um
obviously um
a long day
everyone in washington
glued to the testimony
you've written a book about the supreme
court
several years ago
how did today compare
to previous
hearings like this contentious uh
obviously this is uh quite electric what
happened
did the book the brethren with scott
armstrong and
this book came out in 1979 were you born
it didn't come out in 79 i'll send you a
copy
and
the conclusion in the book at the end
and it supported is that the center of
the court was in control a group of
three or four justices how they went
the left or the right would join with
them i mean now obviously
there
is no center
or very a very small center so that
makes a big difference
on the kavanaugh issue uh
let me tell a story about doing the
book the brethren
the book came out and this is this is a
story about memory which i think is very
important to
the kavanaugh issues
a uh the book came out and a clerk
called scott armstrong and myself and
said in the book on a certain case
you say
that the clerk apologized
for
uh it was
justice rehnquist circulation at that
point and he said i was the clerk
that is absolutely totally wrong
i'm going to sue you
i'm going to
hang you out to dry
i am you know everything you might
possibly do to someone you have to
correct
what's there so we went to our files and
this is the beauty as you know of
documents
and we found
in the files on that case
the circulation in that opinion and the
clerk in his own hand had written i'm
sending this around i apologize
for it
so we called him and said here's
what you wrote and he said i don't
believe it we made xerox and send it to
him and he called back and i think quite
honestly said i would have
staked my children's
life that that did not happen and i now
realize that it did
so
when is memory valid and
as you know in your
terrific reporting you've got
one source doesn't work you've got to
have two sources you have to see if you
can get some sort of documentation and
that takes time and that's hard
did
was the contentiousness today how did
that compare to pork or how did that
compare to thomas and is it different
because of the media
what what's what's interesting uh
the
the democrats are particularly saying
we've got to have an fbi investigation
and they talk as if
fbi investigations
reach conclusions which has been pointed
out they normally don't but sometimes
the evidence is so overwhelming it's
implied in what they report but going
back to the nixon case in watergate the
fbi investigation was part of the
cover-up
and
it was a way to mask
and protect nixon and protect people in
the nixon campaign and the white house
and the attorney general at the time i
remember this
very well richard kleindings went on
television and said
well we conducted 1345
interviews all over the world we we got
it right it's over no one
else was involved in the original
burglars and and their two handlers
and uh
there was that sense of well wait a
minute that's a lot of interviews a lot
of work
and they got it wrong so maybe an f so
it's not always definitive and it may
not always be right
um i'm sure everyone here has seen the
book an enormous amount of attention and
the thing that struck me the most about
the book was that i thought that you
drew
conclusions in a way that you may not
have in previous books you were very
critical of how comey handled his
interactions with the president
when he briefed him on the the dossier
and then your largest conclusion was the
fact that can you imagine you're two
weeks away from becoming president the
fbi director
comes in and there's no way the ghost of
j edgar hoover is not far behind and
says by the way we have this secret
dossier about you being with prostitutes
in moscow three years earlier how would
you feel well
how should comey have handled it
not that way
and and uh
trump has a legitimate beef in my view
and and i say so in the book and uh
being the prisoner of too much history
and writing
too much about presidents
in the case of bill clinton when he came
into office in 1993
and his white house counsel was bernie
nussbaum
and uh first of like six yes that's
right but but the the first and uh
uh if as you imagine uh clinton had some
baggage too and there were all kinds of
things that the fbi got about
clinton's extra
curricular activities which were
abundant and so they sent all this
instead of briefing clinton on it they
sent it to bernie nussbaum the white
house counsel and nussbaum looked at it
and said
put it in the burn bag
and said okay let's see what happens
let's see how these things and i'm not
sure the burn bag is i wish he'd called
me
and
he didn't but
the idea of the fbi director getting in
the face of
somebody like trump who has a big ego
has any uh i quote in the book he
clinton told his lawyer when he was
after this briefing he said oh melania
can never find out about this of course
it was about
two minutes or two days later she did as
did the world yeah and you draw a
conclusion that
the administration is in a very
dangerous spot
and i felt that that is the is that the
furthest you have ever gone and why did
you go so far
uh
evelyn duffy who's my assistant are you
here evelyn
raise your hand evelyn stand up because
a george washington university graduate
class of
and
the year 2007
she's worked for me since actually at
that time and we've done five books four
presidents
and
she knows all the secrets
and she knows how to keep secrets
and she knows how to kick me in the ass
and for that i salute her and gw
but
but evelyn and my wife
elsa walsh
very much involved this was a family
affair and
they both said you cannot step away
from the obvious conclusions
of what you found in the book that there
is there are a group of people which i
illustrate very vividly
who stand up to trump uh steal documents
off his desk
on south korean trade because it's
connected to lots of very sensitive
intelligence operations
documents on nafta
documents on climate change and so forth
it's a regular procedure
get it off the resolute desk and he will
not remember or not think about it and
as i say so and and you've got all of
the other things john dowd his lawyer
uh for the russian investigation for
eight months
can you imagine being trump's lawyer
eight months
and
he goes through and he finally does a
practice session with
with trump and and
in the white house and they're
overlooking the
monuments and
dowd the lawyer plays mueller and asks
questions of trump it's kind of a
dry run and and trump makes things up
lies
loses emotional control and finally
doubt says you cannot testify
if you testify it will be as he
elegantly puts it an orange jumpsuit
and you don't have to
know a lot about law enforcement to
not recognize what that is
and so you connect all of these things
and
my conclusion in the book is that it is
an administration in a white house
that's going through a nervous breakdown
so it's going through a nervous
breakdown
how could it go wrong what would a
manifestation of that look like is it
something on the trade or economic side
is it give us an example of okay it's in
a dangerous spot
what could happen
just on trade and it sounds esoteric but
the the trade war with china
99.9 of the economists
say uh tariffs make no sense they hurt
consumers uh we buy things abroad in
this country because they're cheaper and
they're better quality and uh trump
somehow
has in his head that were they're taking
that money from us they're stealing it
and he will not get that out of his head
and
one of the conclusions i
make is that this is there's a war on
truth and part of it is not just what
trump says but what where trump gets
these ideas and uh
the experts go in and that you know they
have to i mean gary cohn is chief
economic advisors kind of
slaps him gently
in an affectionate
perhaps way
and says uh if
you'd shut the [ __ ] up you would learn
something
[Applause]
so you you've got to connect it but i
i think it's uh
and i
it's not partisan this isn't a partisan
i mean i it may ask you a question sure
will you answer maybe okay
do you i mean you
you've done great reporting great
digging reporting on the mueller
investigation and lots of new
information has come
largely
through you quite frankly and do you
consider yourself part of the resistance
no not at all
what are you then i'm um
simply out to follow the story wherever
it goes
no matter whether it's good bad or
otherwise for either side suppose
mueller goes on for several more months
and says you know
i can't prove
collusion with russia by trump or anyone
in a
close somebody close to him and that
there's no obstruction of justice i can
prove are you going to feel badly
no what are you going to feel
i'm going to try and find out why he
didn't get to that conclusion do you
think that's possible he would reach
that conclusion very possible you do
as possible as any as the other
possibility yeah then he would
and so how do you insulate yourself
emotionally
we should have had a couple of couches
here rather than chairs
so three times a week i see my therapist
yeah
um
i
just simply say that like
i try and divorce myself as much as
possible i didn't vote in 16 i didn't
vote in 12 and that for me enabled me to
push myself away and say okay i'm sort
of an outsider to this i'm sort of like
it's like you kind of look up and i look
at it like trying to cover the weather
it's like there's a big storm in front
of you and i'm trying to see different
parts of it
and
i can't really affect the weather and
it's not my job to affect the weather
it's just my job to try and figure out
the weather
and just try and follow it where it can
yeah
and uh
when
right after nixon resigned in 1974
catherine graham who was the publisher
owner of of the washington post sent
carl bernstein and myself a letter and
kind of
it was a
lovely
letter of personal advice and she said
you know now this has happened
nixon's gone
don't get too full of yourself and then
she said
beware the demon pomposity
and
that was really good advice because
there's a lot of pomposity in our
business in politics
even academia academia occasionally
and
it is the it is the crippling force i
think
and you have to really try to bleach out
i love your analogy it's the weather and
you you know you can get up and kind of
say an awful storm is coming but that
doesn't mean you're blaming
the creator or
it means
you're reporting and i think there's a
way
to stay on
this side of the
non-resistance
and to be very empirical and very
factual
and uh
because i i've done this uh
so many years sometimes you're just
wrong
you're i thought the ford pardon of
of uh nixon
uh was really the last stage of the
cover-up and then i investigated and
discovered actually it was an act of
courage
to
let the country move on and so that's
very sobering i think one thing that i
had always keep in the front of my mind
and especially
with the time pressures that that i'm
under is that i'm always one step from
the gutter i'm always one bad tweet away
from destroying my reputation i'm always
one you know wrong story away from
hurting myself
and
it you know it's just it can be too but
not only yourself
the new york times
and uh
this is where you've got to find i mean
bradley the great editor of the
post during watergate and for a couple
of decades used to i so well remember
this
hand in a story and he'd look at it and
he'd go
you don't have it yet
that
meant
we'll print it if you do get it but
you've got to have more information and
more sources and
i always said and believed he was great
editor
not just because of what he published
but what he kept out yeah
are there those filters at the new york
times for you
there's a lot of time where we run up to
write a story where we we get ready we
write it we go to folks to get a
response and then in that last 12 hours
we realize we don't have it and then we
kind of recede back we wrote a story
earlier this year on
trump uh on john dowd offering pardons
talking about pardons to the
lawyers for manafort and flynn and we
ran up to the line three times it was
kind of like you know like a goal line
stand and we're three yards out we tr
first down we tried and we didn't have
it and we pulled and we didn't run it
second time and then the third but in
that process you flush out
a lot of dude and you didn't run it
eventually and he still denies it
correctly he's still denied he denies a
lot of things yeah
and there's a lot
um
how did um
did you think the president was well
served by john dowd and john downstage
john daddy who left in march you know
it's an interesting question some people
think definitely not by turning all over
all the evidence over and 37 witnesses
and who's the
17 hours of tape of don mcgahn's
notes
which are supposedly
very intimate and very important uh and
then other people say you know it was a
gamble and you had to take it
if you're
trump's lawyer because you have to
keep him from testifying
and if he testifies that would be
the legal and political catastrophe do
you agree
if he testifies yeah yeah i
i mean he struggles with the truth more
than any public figure right now so so
how do we deal with that well and
especially because mueller has shown a
very quick trigger on that issue so he's
rung up several folks on lying to
investigators
some of the things significant some less
so
and
the president is not someone obsessed
with the facts so what are the
so what are the techniques you use as a
reporter
to get verification because i think
that's very i think that's something we
don't
communicate to the public enough about
that
can you answer that without
betraying trade it's
um
there's a there's a bunch of factors one
of them is your proximity to the
information how close are you to the
information
how historically helpful and accurate
have you been there are people that are
in the room
that
are amidst all these big decisions that
that that they don't bat a thousand they
don't have great memory of what goes on
in front of them they don't have great
notes they don't have great documents
um
you sort of look at the totality of all
of these different things we had this
recently with the rod rosenstein story
about how
rod rosenstein had talked about wiring
himself up or using the 25th amendment
to oust the president
in the end it fell into sort of two
buckets of information there was
months and months of reporting that
from folks that had access to
contemporaneous notes that had access to
folks that were in the room that knew
everything that was going on in real
time and that had a track record of
being accurate and being truthful and
then in the other bucket we had one
person who was a handout from the
justice department who was an anonymous
person who said it was sarcastic
so we step back and you look at them and
you look at the totality
how did you do that how did you get past
that in the book yeah that's
what um
i have found over doing this for decades
and all these presidents you you can
hear something you can say well there's
uh like
i knew from all kinds of people there's
great tension
between
h.r mcmaster who was the national
security advisor and rex tillerson the
secretary of state and they really had
it out
and somebody said there was a meeting
and in the summer
and they had they had a big fight about
it and then
uh i found somebody who actually took
notes
and the notes
say tuesday
january 18th
5 15.
reince priebus's office the chief of
staff at the time and then there are
verbatims
and it turns out
that priebus was doing kind of a routine
review with tillerson are you achieving
your big goals
and
in walks mcmaster
to the meeting and sits down and
tillerson lets loose on the white house
the
you know the president can't make a
decision he makes a decision he
undecides he re-decides there's chaos
here and then finally mcmaster just
rages at tillerson and says you know i'm
in the money line is you are
affirmatively
acting to undermine the national
security process i don't know what
you're doing and i've i found some
examples and evelyn
found that oh yeah one of these examples
is clearly in the public record that
tillerson had made
a
anti-terrorist
agreement that was public with
the oil rich state of gutter and
he mcmaster didn't know about it and
they started talking about it and they
realized
tillerson actually had a press
conference and gutter saying we've been
working on this for weeks and mcmaster
says you know i did not even know and
then they discover the president didn't
know the staff secretary rob porter
didn't know and so you
you put dates and documents and
verbatims and
i always am suspicious
uh when somebody says one afternoon in
may
well
what day in may
what what time who was there what was
said and if you can get that kind of
granularity now it
i have the luxury of time to work on
these things and go back and find
sources who
who have notes and and documents which i
think are
much more important than we realize
um we're gonna take questions if folks
would like to line up there might there
are two microphones in the back um you
want to tell them the microphones have
been provided by gordon liddy
see i mean how do people who were in
college know who gordon liddy is
when when you um
you put out this book enormous amount of
attention
certain
things like taking the
the letter or off the desk gets a lot of
attention
what telling reporting did you do that
you felt really sometimes we do this we
do great reporting
and it doesn't get as much attention and
people sort of miss and you said man you
know i killed myself to do that
and it kind of fell flat yeah
but what there was a rationale for doing
it and because at risk was a special
access program one of the great secret
intelligence operations that
i i don't do not dare describe because
it buys a degree of security for this
country that we don't realize and then i
actually got the document and got a
picture of it and put it in the book so
if somebody like president trump said oh
if that had happened i would have fired
gary cohen who had done it in two
seconds but you know there it is
and uh so
there's a kind of uh
you can't
get around that you can't get around
some of the things
but uh we you know there is this war of
truth going on and you some of your best
stories
that i know are true
have been denied and sometimes the
stronger
the denial is the more truth that's
there
and like the rosenstein rosenstein story
about
talking about wiring himself or somebody
to
get the president on tape and talking
about the 25th amendment
that story would have been much more
powerful if there was action that
followed if you've kind of said had a
picture in the new york times here is
the wire
that the deputy attorney general
wore
in the meeting with the president or
at
2 15 on this day these cabinet officers
got together and talked about
the 25th amendment so
lots of things are said
in the end
it's what's
done and i tried to make this a book
about what president
trump does as president in all the
foreign policy areas all
the trade the tax areas the things that
matter
to people's lives
if
there's been a lot of focus on the
mueller investigation for very good
reason there's been a lot of focus on
all the untruths that trump tells i mean
my paper
has counted what four thousand or two i
don't know
it's in the thousands
and uh the real
issue is and evelyn and my wife elsa
helped me with this well what did he do
as president
is there a theme to the president's
decision making
it
it often is
people will say you know these are the
facts we win
85.7
of our
cases in the world trade organization
where we file
unfair trade practices against country
countries and the president said that's
the worst organization in the world and
they say well this is your government
your
trade representative lighthizer call him
and check the i don't want to call
i don't want to know
and often
uh he will say i mean there there's one
scene that's startling that they had
where where do you get these ideas he
said well i've had them for 30
years and if you disagree you're wrong
and so there is the that's the same
the closed mind which of course
leads you to the question what what
should we really worry about we should
worry
about a crisis something unexpected
because
it's not a team
uh first question
good evening gentlemen mr woodward uh
thank you so much for being here tonight
it's a tremendous honor to be able to
see you my name is elliot belkrauser and
i'm a proud gw colonial class of 2008
from
the columbian college of poli-sci
when you and mr bernstein were covering
president nixon in the watergate
investigation in 1973 and 74 you and um
the washington post and other newspapers
faced threats and uh you know um
things that i can't even imagine in
today but today it seems that the free
press is under assault worse than ever
how in your opinion does what happened
to you and the post and other
journalists in 1973 74 compare to what
is happening today
i'm sorry what's the question i bet
there's
the criticisms of the press when you're
covering watergate
how does that compare to the criticisms
of today
uh well uh nixon uh and his spokespeople
were pretty tough we were called
character assassins
and uh
the original fake news yeah but you know
i'd rather be called fake news than a
character assassin i'm sorry
neither but
answer the question this way it was
january 1973
carl and i had written these stories
that really let
said watergate was a nixon white house
re-election campaign operation
and the key was that it wasn't just the
watergate burglary it was a series of
sabotage and espionage
operations and
we had a bit of a problem no one
believed the stories
nixon won a massive
uh
in november of 72. so katherine graham
invited me
for lunch
in
uh
january of 73 and she'd supported the
story and i knew her a little bit but
not well and
carl had to go to a funeral that day and
so she sat down
at in her lunch room and
said well uh
and she truly blew my mind with
how she knew the facts of watergate
had all kinds of questions uh she even
at one point said she'd
read something
about watergate in the chicago tribune
and i remember thinking what the hell is
she reading the chicago tribune for
no one in chicago does
but there she was scooping up the
information and
had a leadership style i later described
his mind on hands off didn't tell us how
to do things but was intellectually
involved and completely informed
and
she
said at one point well when's the truth
going to come out and i said you know i
think uh because the cover-up is very
effective because people won't talk to
us now that nixon has won reelection
because they pay paying the five
watergate burglars for their silence
uh never and she i remember she just
was had this pained wounded look on her
face any of your bosses at the new york
times ever had that look sometimes yeah
maybe it's you hate it
uh and uh she said
i and
i said so the answer is
it's never
going to come out she said
quote never don't tell me never
and i left the lunch a highly motivated
employee
but it wasn't a threat it was a
statement of purpose
and she
i mean this is the strength of real
gutsy leadership in the news media and
and she said to me said why do you think
we're doing this
and i i was 29 i didn't have an answer
and she said
look
this involves the president of the
united states we have a triple quadruple
responsibility to get to the bottom of
it so keep
working instead of
pulling back
go forward more aggressively
and
and why do we do this and
again you know i i don't have an answer
and and she gave the great answer
because that's the business we're in
and
that's
you know somebody really saying
ah
willing to assume the risk
the necessity of assuming their risk
question
uh we got a post guy and a times guy
there
and i like to know what the post guy
thinks of the new york times
anonymous
editorial or op-ed or whatever it was
and
what he thinks of the substance and
secondly what he thinks of
publishing an anonymous uh
case like that it's a great question
let's let michael answer first
suppose anonymous
somebody in a
well-placed position in the new york
times said i want you
to write a story quoting me
essentially saying what's in that op-ed
piece what would you have done we would
need many more details and examples
5 15
july
18th
specifics yes specifics and how would
you have gone about that you would i
would have pushed them question them and
then asked if they have anything to
corroborate what they're saying yeah
because it's easy to sit and say you
know this administration's a mess but
it's much more powerful to show an
example of it like your book is filled
with them
if anonymous had come to me i would have
said go to the new york times
[Applause]
mr woodward thank you so much for being
here tonight i i feel like you're the
most qualified person on the planet who
can answer this question for me the the
great journalist of another era upton
sinclair said you can't make somebody
understand something if their salary
depends upon them not understanding it
how do you get truth from someone who
genuinely believes the delusion that
they're buying into and you need to get
truth from them but
they just can't accept truth
oh wow
you know this sounds like a philosophy
523 at gw
uh
you know what you you want to deal in
concrete things and let me answer it
this way can we
do a little role playing here i'm
reporter i'm me
you're the assistant secretary of
defense and i've come to interview you
now what's going through your head
um
why is he here what is he going to ask
me where am i vulnerable
vulnerable
and maybe the truth
makes you where am i
where am i vulnerable personally and
where is the administration potentially
so i'm going to come in and i'm going to
start asking you things and then
i'm going to get out a piece of paper
and i'm going to say
mr assistant secretary
in an article in defense news
32 years ago you wrote the following and
i'm going to quote it
and you might think i thought only my
mother read that damn article
and here's this guy coming in quote it
now
it's not a ruse i want to know how you
think
the larger theory of the case is
to treat you as seriously as you treat
yourself
as you look at yourself you take
yourself seriously right
i have to take yourself you seriously
and really
i'm getting that detail and then if
you're helpful i'm going to say
can i come back
and then
after two or three interviews if it's
useful i'm going to say you know how
about talking next week well i'm busy
next week and then i find out where you
live
and i come knocking on your door right
then i say oh [ __ ] bob woodward's here
right
and do you let me in
probably why
i don't it's hard to turn people away
yeah i think it's hard i think it's hard
for people to turn away other people
yes i think it's harder than people and
i my line on this is we're not showing
up enough
and uh we've got to really show up and
it means physical presence we're doing
you know people will crowd around
the uh
computer say oh we've asked the white
house for comment on and you know three
people over at the white house are
saying how can we respond to this and
not say anything of substance
and
you gotta
get out of that mode
and you have to get out of the
impatience and speed mode we gotta have
this
it's so competitive i mean you read i
suspect i hope the washington post as
soon as it comes out each night and it's
kind of a continuum
and
do you
like it when the post has a good story
or not i don't like it at all you don't
yeah
not at all not well
actually
this room this reminds me of something
that i recently read in a book
what did you do after psy hirsch in
early 1973 who psy hershey came down for
the times to cover watergate
nixon had been reelected it's that same
period of time where you go out to lunch
with katherine graham what did you do
after sci hirsch wrote a story in the
times what was the story that was really
was the story about the watergate
burglars
being paid i called him up and said
thank you why
well because we were alone
and it was a it was a
key
piece of evidence to the cover-up that
they would pay actual money
to for family support and
lawyers fees and so forth it was a
stunning story
the other side of it was i felt agony
that we did not have that story but
it was such a good story and
it um
it really lifted our spirits well it
validated it showed another experienced
reporter sort of on the same path right
in a good way yeah and and
not
buying the line of course the line then
45 years ago was very much what we hear
now
let's examine the conduct of the press
not the conduct of the president
hello gentlemen thank you both for being
here tonight
my name is ethan moran and i'm currently
a 10th grader at sandy spring friends
school
[Music]
mr woodward you've had one of the most
successful careers in journalism in
american history and i was wondering how
a high schooler like myself would go
about
following a career like yourself in
journalism or politics
get an internship at the new york times
they're really easy to get
isn't that the way you started i started
answering the phones they wouldn't even
let me be an intern
i had to start answering the phones and
how did you move up i mean this is um so
i started at the times um at a college
as a clerk
on the copy on the foreign desk and it
was my job to do two things one was to
get reporters in iraq in the middle east
on the phone with editors at the new
york times who don't know how to dial
their own phone
um and the other one was to take calls
from judy miller from jail because the
only number she remembered was to find
it
but just being in the newsroom
gave me an enormous opportunity and i
basically said i will take any
assignment possible i will i covered
murders in the bronx
and i eventually got a break in sports
by doing steinbrenner duty by standing
outside yankee stadium and getting a
quote from george steinbrenner so i did
a lot of low end things that no one
wanted to do
because i knew that they could lead to
other things down the line and i think
if you take that attitude you can really
go and get your foot in the door yeah
you got to get in the fact that i was in
the door
and
just real quickly
jeff bezos who owns the washington post
the amazon ceo
i asked him once said how do you decide
who to hire because this
applies to your question and he said
well quickly said i have four criteria
uh i like people who've been right a lot
i like people who listen really listen
not strategic listening where you know
you're listening so you can think of
what you're to say rather than letting
it come in
people he likes to hire people who
change their mind i think that's
important and then his fourth criteria
is
most fascinating he said i like to hire
people who have failed
and are still standing
that you learn
from failure
and you can't fail and
be gone you got to still stand and then
bezos will hire you
next question
will we ever see donald trump's tax
returns
between now and the end of time yes um
well maybe not sometimes you know they
never come out uh i think in terms of uh
really getting uh
traveling that painful road of
introspection
i think it's one of the media's failures
i think
personally my failure because i was
working on his tax returns in 2016 and
we did not get them i did not get them
and
we should have because people in the irs
have said
very confidentially
in a very confidential way if you had
these this is the road map
to his life and who he is and uh
i think also we did not find or the
political system didn't find a way to
demand that he turn over his tax returns
he just said no and of course that's the
trump you know i'm going to
do it my way one of the failures and i
think
if you ask a group like this
how many people basically distrust the
media can i ask the how many people
basically distrust the media raise your
hands
okay not many you can tell it's a
college
audience
but you can go to an audience and and
get
90 of the people who will say they
distrust the media and so there's enough
distrust out there and
whether it's 20 or 30 percent or what
it's too high and we can't blame
the customers we've got to think about
fixing it ourselves and being more
empirical being
no
you know
getting on tv i think is a dangerous
have you found that yeah totally yeah
yeah you say things on tv that you won't
put in your stories well i shouldn't
do you no did you ask me or do you think
i did either way no i try not to say
i try not to say anything on television
that i had that i haven't written one of
your editors told me they heard you say
something on television and they said
why wasn't that in the story
that's the problem that's the problem
yeah but do you think tv for print
journalists at my paper your paper a
good thing
i think that it's another way to reach
folks
and i think that when people see us
and they see that we're fact-based
people that are trying to tell a story i
think that that can be helpful i do and
i think that we need to be out there
more
explaining our work and showing
ourselves because when we're just a
byline
and
there's not much more then other things
can fester about us and it's gotta be it
can be tough but it's got to be neutral
hugh hewitt who a conservative
radio talk show host i went on his show
and he said of he found things in my
book that actually made trump look
strong and he liked that and he said i'm
going to buy lots of the books and
airdrop them into every embassy in
washington
that'd be a lot of books i i gave him
the address where he can buy them at the
discount but i don't think he ever did
it but i
quite honestly was heartened by
somebody like that saying oh there are
things here
and
also the explanatory
part of
how trump because it shows that it's
fair it's a fair assessment
it's tough though when when trump last
month called me to complain
that
i hadn't interviewed him
and first thing i said i'd like to tape
record this
uh mr president and he said certainly
and then
i said i'd tried six people
and didn't get through and he
acknowledged one or two and it was a
strength did you read this what did you
think of that
well what would you have asked him if
you could have interviewed
but
if i asked a question yeah
the book was already printed
and what do we do have a kind of
uh pamphlet that we stick in in the back
and kind of say well trump called and i
i
i looked at it as i had the no but if
you
if you had sat down with him
what would you have asked him
i mean ultimately you want to get
to
specifics but you want to ask the
question why
what is
what is the big
theory
why what are you trying to do what's the
next stage of good for a majority of
people in the country that's your
constituency
um we have to wrap things up but i
wanted to end it by having you read the
last paragraph of the book which i think
is a great
summary um sort of of what you had found
and
it's just a good way to sort of end
things
well evelyn wrote this paragraph
no she did not but she helped me as did
elsa
but this is about dowd the lawyer who
has resigned because he just said i
cannot sit sit next to you mr president
and have you destroy yourself
and not tell the truth and he said
you're incapable of telling the truth
you're disabled so this is doubt but in
but in the man and his presidency john
dowd had seen the tragic flaw
in the political back and forth the
evasions
the denials the tweeting
the obscuring the crying fake news the
indignation
trump had one overriding problem that
dowd knew
but could not bring himself to say
to the president
you're a [ __ ] liar
thank you very much
create a more inclusive democratic party
good evening and um and welcome to pnp
live i'm brad graham the co-owner of
politics and pros along with my wife
lisa muscatine and we have a great
program for you this evening
for those of you not familiar with how
this virtual format works you'll still
be able to ask a question of the author
if you'd like
to do so just click on the q a icon at
the bottom of your screen
bob woodward has been observing and
reporting in washington for half a
century
in his decades with the washington post
he's covered nine presidents and shared
in two pulitzer prizes first for the
post coverage of the watergate scandal
and second in 2003 as the lead reporter
for coverage of the 911 terrorist
attacks
his books also have made big news and
drawn many readers
his newest book rage
is bob's 20th
all have been national bestsellers
we're accustomed to bob's books taking
us behind the scenes of high-level
meetings and into the minds of those
making critical us policy decisions
it's extraordinary about rage is at this
time donald trump himself spoke with bob
not once or twice but 17 times while the
book was being written providing a
remarkable series of glimpses into the
president's thinking at key moments
conversation with bob this evening will
be another prize-winning journalist jane
mayer chief washington correspondent for
the new yorker magazine where she's been
for 25 years
jake's also the author of four
authoritative books
that have helped deepen our
understanding of such important topics
as the money behind the rise of the
radical right
the war on terror the clarence thomas
hearings and the iran-contra affair
so jane and bob take it away
all right hey bob great to be with you
and thank you jane
so
um i just wanted to start as um
given that there's been so much news
um with a question or two to get your
thoughts on the court and i wondered
whether in your work on
trump whether you had gotten any
insights into his relationship with
mitch mcconnell
how do they work together will they be
coordinating closely and do they have
the same interests when it comes to
approaching
um the fulfilling the vacancy left by
ruth bader ginsburg's death yes because
you have a piece in the new yorker
remind everyone what's uh what your
piece said and your you know idea that
really mcconnell wants to make sure he
retains control of the senate more than
getting another justice is that correct
well i think what he'd like is to do
both
um
and my guess is that he'll he'll be
um
you know he's very canny and will find a
way to do both with some incredible
maneuver he often surprises people with
a fine print of the rules in the senate
but
i i think people i know who i've
interviewed about mitch mcconnell think
that nothing matters more to him
than staying majority leader put it that
way um but i i imagine at this point
trump
um really wants yet another justice that
this would be his third on the court and
i i'm sure mitch would like it too but
not at the expense of losing losing his
um majority in the senate and it's dicey
politics right now as we know things are
very vulnerable so what do you think's
going on how do they how do they work
together dude have you gotten any well
i'm going to release
some audio and transcripts of
trump talking with me about this very
issue i think we're going to release him
in an hour but
it shows
that
trump and mcconnell really work in
tandem
much more than we thought
uh the trap
trump has wrapped his his mind around
this issue of filling the seat uh
the next the ruth bader ginsburg uh seat
he sees a political plus
a in fact a giant one because what this
does
it takes the focus off the virus
where his performance is
quite frankly i found in my reporting
abysmal
and uh
goes to the issue of
can they he put another justice on the
court
and uh this this fits uh his idea of
uh
you know a lack of decorum
is very much his style and he's he's
people are criticizing him saying this
is not fair but this is a pure political
power play
that mcconnell and trump might pull off
quite successfully people and democrats
and a lot of people said wait a minute
merrick garland didn't get a hearing
didn't get a vote
and
in reality the senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell controls these things so
there's much much more
i i think this is trump luck when
one of the long conversations i had with
trump a couple of months ago he said he
thought in 2016 he won the election in
the last four years
four weeks of the campaign i think you
can see that
and argue that and i think he's hoping
to
duplicate that
you know you have in your book a
conversation i i it seems with i don't
know if you directly interviewed him but
with lindsey graham and he and you say
that lindsey graham and chief justice
john roberts talk a lot
and um which was news to me and that um
lindsey graham's the chairman of the
judiciary committee in the senate right
now um and a key
pivotal position in all of this in all
of this and but it's it
you in in the book graham seems to
express that he's
worried that the core and and and
justice roberts too chief robert stu are
both worried that the court has become
so split and so politicized and so
partisan
and they don't want it to become more so
does that suggest do you think that that
kind of thinking will have any bearing
on who trump picks or how will he make
this pick do you think well i i think
he's he's going to uh pick the uh the
woman the cuban-american from florida i
it makes all the political sense in in
the world uh she
served on the
supreme court of florida for many years
now she's on the federal
appeals court down there
and
that cuban american heritage
conservative
it's an obvious political
pick for trump but you know
in trump world you learn to not
stake much on your predictions because
he continually surprises but this this
is going to be
as everyone says bloody but trump and
mcconnell are looking at this oh boy we
have an opportunity
here
and it appeals to the evangelicals
it appeals to this idea of
the the kind of
rule breaking that trump loves uh
in a way there's a tradition of not
trying to
ram through
a supreme court a
new appointee
in the
election year let alone the last 50 days
of the campaign so uh i think there's a
feeling of
uh political muscle and
uh that uh they're good they're gonna
exercise it and a lot of people don't
like this and you don't see it as any
kind of potential for backlash um i mean
i know the democrats are already talking
about if they take the senate majority
that they would then um
also turn to sort of radical muscle and
and and maybe try to pack the court or
something like that you do you see any
sort of downside for the i know there
are people who talk about that packing
the court is has a bad odor about it
because franklin roosevelt tried that
and it's kind of we don't like the way
the court is or the way the court has
been in all of american history and
we're going to now add more justices
because we don't like what they're doing
i don't think
that works in a political sense or in a
practical sense but
if you listen to some of the democrats
talk about this and just say oh this
this is uh
absolutely awful unfair how can trump
and mcconnell think of doing what do you
think you know this i mean i think that
that that
mcconnell and and i don't know i haven't
spent as much time maybe as certainly
not as much time as you have on trump
but mcconnell
um as somebody wrote today
hypocrisy
hypocrisy and shamelessness are not only
is he immune to them they're a
management style for him i mean this is
this is business as usual for him
they're not going to care if people say
it looks unfair that is not going to
well but but who are the people who are
going to say it's unfair democrats
democrats all right and and what is the
that's not going to stop the only thing
i can imagine that might make it where
it might make a difference is um and i
was interviewing norm ornstein about
this from aei is that their couple races
senate races with in endangered
republican incumbents susan collins in
maine for instance who's already
declared that she's not going to vote
for um
you know for a replacement for ginsburg
before the election um and there are a
few others where it could be dicey that
puts them on the spot of having to
choose between the trump base which they
can't afford to lose and the moderates
and particularly women who they might
not want to lose um but i i can't count
to you're going to need four who would
not vote um with mcconnell four
republicans and i i and today i can't
count to four of them i can't figure
they might get romney they might with
murkowski and collins i don't know who
the fourth would be
so um anyway but you know we're
everybody's watching
and certainly but but
that the idea of hypocrisy what what's
the hypocrisy
no it's not going to hurt their feelings
yeah i mean it it it
actually i think is kind of the wrong
word it is
plain ultimate political hardball
and
as we know the democrats will do that as
will the republicans so
it's going to be
a moment where you have to sit on the
edge of your seat
because
uh they're going to be maneuvers they're
gonna
they're gonna be surprises
uh and
trump is sitting back there
wow we're talking about this rather than
the virus which has now killed
200 000 people and i found in my
reporting my discussions
with trump and this all goes back to and
if i can take you to
i think what is the one of the most
important meetings in the oval office
certainly in this
century and maybe in a long time and
that's january 28th
of this year when the national security
adviser robert o'brien said to president
trump
the virus is going to be
not maybe but going to be the biggest
national security threat to your
presidency and then matt pottinger the
deputy laid out the details of how
pottinger had sources he was an old wall
street journal reporter a very talented
one was nominated for a pulitzer prize
uh for what he did
in china for seven years covering the
2003
sars epidemic and he laid out for trump
he said look this will this virus is
airborne
people who don't show symptoms can
spread it but most importantly he said
this is not going to be just a little
problem it's going to be very much like
the 1918
spanish flu pandemic that killed 675
000 people they went through the details
of this and the president
10 days later told me about this i was
thinking all about
he's talking about china and it was not
for three months until i learned about
that january meeting which uh
i start my book with
it is one of those it's almost like
somebody coming to franklin roosevelt
a week before pearl harbor and saying
the japanese are going to bomb us
and just sitting on it and not doing
anything it's it's it's shocking
behavior
it is uh
i think there are two pillars in the
presidency
the first is i remember talking to trump
about this in our first interview
in december of last year in the oval
office
and the question was
what's the job of the president and and
trump said the job is to protect the
people
and he failed here to protect the people
what he could have done in february
coming out and say look i have an
authoritative warning here
uh there's things people can do he
literally in the state of the union
address february 4th could have said
wash your hands keep social distance
wear a mask don't get in a room crowded
room with people for an
extended period of time
that kind of remedial behavior
you know there are models that say
tens of thousands of lives could have
been saved by acting in february so bob
i mean the story you lay out here i
think is shocking and and
egregious
why do you think trump
acted this way what was going on in his
head i know he has said
that he he purposely downplayed it to
avoid a panic
but is that really it because if he's so
concerned about panic
in the public why
he spends an awful lot of time torquing
up fear
about things like race riots so he
doesn't seem concerned about that
particular panic was he and i did see in
your book that um that his chief of
staff meadows was concerned particularly
about the stock market maybe dropping
what was going on what how do you
account for his failure on this issue
that is now killed as of today
um 200 000 people in this
i mean if we've been talking a year ago
and i said oh that's going to happen
next year you would think i've gone off
the rails right
i mean it's it it's
a shocking number so your question on
march 19th i interviewed him in
one of our many talks over nine hours
and he
uh and i said why have you acted this
way
about the virus now this is march
everyone knew it was airborne knew that
we were in
a crisis we were
at that point there were 30 000 new
cases a day so i said why are you doing
instead he said well i
like to downplay it i've always liked to
downplay it i don't want people to panic
and i now
look at that statement
and uh to be very direct with you when
he said
i don't want people to panic it reflects
his failure to understand the people
he governs
that in this country if people are told
the truth and say like franklin
roosevelt after pearl harbor said i know
you can be
told the worst it's all bad news and you
will not lose heart that is the american
tradition
if you lay it on the line and say look
this is going to be difficult but trump
wanted to cover it up and
for all the
almost 50 years writing about trying to
understand presidents it is
it is the
action
that uh
really is
a failure
to
lead in any form
a
failure to understand his responsibility
as we know
it's not i mean during some of this
the experts like dr faunchi were saying
oh at the end of february it's okay to
go to the gym in the mall and the movies
uh
you know maybe it will be different but
i think right now it's going to be fine
and people are saying well
the public officials of health officials
let trump down but
you know this so well there are two
strains two information
routes to a president one is national
security and the other
is the doctors coming in for these uh
these uh
coronavirus task force meetings but they
don't meet except trump's the only one
who's at all of them he knows what's
going on and uh the failure to
warn is one of the saddest moments in
history
as best i can tell do you think he felt
that he could somehow outrun it though i
mean it's you know as you watch the
numbers
and they're exponentially ticking
upwards and spreading through the
country did he think people wouldn't
notice i that's what i i've have been
unable
you see that's not the way
uh he thinks he thinks in a very
impulsive way as we know what how do i
deal with this at this moment
and uh it's a failure to accept
responsibility in
july i talked with him one of our long
talks uh in fact it's the longest one
that's in the book so this is two months
ago and i i said on the virus
what grade would you give yourself
and he said uh well i would give myself
an a and if we get a vaccine an a plus
now on
this day there were four
million
virus cases in this country 142
000 americans had died
and he's giving himself an a
and then you look at some of his
comments the last week when you know
people ask about him down playing and he
said well i actually up played it
now that is a word i checked that's not
even in the scramble dictionary let
alone the real uh big dictionary and uh
he's
one moment he's saying my book is a
political hit job he was asked on
by a fox anchor this week well what
about the book is it accurate and trump
said uh well it's okay it's fine
and you know up down
a political hit job and uh he
i'm sorry to say this you listen to this
and i'm not sure he knows which way is
up and which way is down
that adds and
compounds the problem this is the leader
of our country
well
bob you've covered
nine
presidents um and
um i guess i just have to ask the the
most basic of questions is trump the
worst
well you see i'm
as a reporter you want to cover
each one and you could make all kinds of
comparisons and
nixon
the first president i covered with carl
bernstein
and he clearly was a criminal president
and the republican party turned on nixon
and he was really forced to resign when
barry goldwater went to the oval office
and said i've counted the republicans
and
you have only four votes among
republicans none in the democratic party
and one of those four votes for you is
not me
goldwater said the next night nixon
announced he was resigning so it's each
one is
different
uh
this this has left a
gaping wound
in our country
and it's not over
almost a thousand people are dying every
day right now
and
the
failure to
lead and describe the things that need
to be done
the experts say if trump would just say
everyone should bear a man wear a pass
he said oh well it's optional it's up to
you then he goes and has
these rallies where thousands of people
are packed together without masks um
what the hell is going on i i think i i
think it's a it's a can
when i did the first book on trump um
fear i said that it's a nervous
breakdown of the executive branch well i
mean what do you call it now what do you
think
i call it something that
we've almost been put to sleep oh a
thousand deaths
142 000 deaths now
200 000 deaths
we need a we need a wake-up call
to
the populace this isn't a political
issue this
this is a practical issue and quite
frankly a moral issue
well in in the i guess the reason i ask
about whether whether you rank trump
differently in sierra at the bottom
partly is a is because as far as i know
and correct me if i'm wrong but this may
be the first president where you have
come out and expressed an opinion that
simply says this man is not qualified to
be our president and and what i said is
he's
in totality from my
not fit for the dog reporting he's the
wrong man for the job in which the
conclusion based on overwhelming
evidence how
could because in in a way
the book is about the truth are we going
to face the truth as i was working on
the epilogue i typed that and then i
consulted
my assistants evelyn duffy steve riley
blessed them and my wife elsa
elsa walsh who you know so well my
colleague
yeah
yeah and somebody uh elsa worked at the
post she was a staff writer at the new
yorker she's she edited this book
six times she repeatedly
uh
would would take me to the woodshed
frankly say wait a minute you haven't
absolutely confirmed this you need to
talk to this person she would give me
drafts and i would have 250 words on a
page typed out neatly and then she would
go after it and actually write more than
250
words on the page editing cutting
rearranging and so forth and uh i'm
i am blessed you know or as a friend i
know her as a wife and a friend and
uh
but i i mean the question i had was you
know this process you went through
of
coming out of your your your that you
are pretty much the most famous and
accomplished reporter in america and you
come out of a tradition
of trying to keep your voice neutral
even as and let the reporting tell the
story and in this case you actually
spoke up as an individual and said
it issued an opinion and i can imagine
that must have been
it's kind of
it's a hard step to take for people like
you and like me maybe who are trained as
traditional reporters and i wonder what
is it about trump that made you feel
that this was the time you actually had
to speak up and say something out loud
in the end conclusion
not only was i able to do the reporting
and have the luxury of 10 months but he
would call me at all hours i could call
him at any time he would call back or he
would come on the phone at night or
during the day if if you go through the
book and say i've got 20 or 10 generals
waiting downstairs i need to go talk to
them like he needed to talk to you i
mean and i guess one of the questions of
course everyone wonders about is
why did he talk to you
and why why do people but why did he
talk to you because he kept saying
throughout the book you know i know this
is going to be bad you're going to do
this you're going to do that um he
didn't talk to you for your first book
what
what it did you think he thought he
could somehow win you over or change the
the the sort of the mainstream media's
view of him
he could sell you on himself or did he
need someone to confess to late at night
as he rambled around the white house
what was going on what do you think this
why did he talk to you
you know i what i'm doing
as you know reporting is a very
practical exercise and i would lay out
my questions and he would answer i would
not let him off the hook
uh if you
go through the book one of the most
extra ordinary scenes for me was going
down to mar-a-lago to interview him
on december 30th of last year he's going
he's on trial
impeachment trial is going on he's
in the
senate and
so i started asking him some questions
about impeachment and the transcript he
released
showing that he wanted the ukrainian
president zielinski to
talk to the attorney general about
investigating
joe biden and his son
so we're shouting at each other i'm
saying and how you by releasing this
transcript nixon famously said he gave
his opponents a sword
by
behaving the way he did and so i said to
president trump you know it's you gave
your opponents a sword
by releasing that transcript oh no that
transcript is perfect so we're going
through it and
uh you you fretted it and i'm just
saying wait a minute wait a minute
uh
why did you do this well it's perfect
well you're saying
let's investigate
uh the bidens
and let's get you talked to the attorney
general
president mr president of ukraine and
trump said no no it's about corruption
and i'm saying no wait a minute read it
right here
it says the minds and
and he would
go on and on and deny it deny it and i
and i said well just as a matter of
policy
do you think
that the president of the united states
should go around asking foreign leaders
to investigate
his political opponents and he wouldn't
hear he said it's perfect if i hadn't
released the transcript
i would have uh really been in trouble
on this he thought it was a shield when
it actually
was a sword for everyone else finally i
said you do you
understand often
how cleansing it is to apologize have
you thought of apologizing absolutely
you i can't believe you thought you'd
get him to apologize well he apologized
uh
for the excess hollywood tape right and
uh
and i said go talk to ivanka
you know walk around this wonderful
place and see see what she says and said
wouldn't he said it wouldn't make any
difference what she said i'm sure that's
true but
that is the interrogation of dominating
an impeached president
on trial in the senate that the senate
and the house could not do and you you
could just you could hear it
i'm going to go on
one of the networks and play
the tape of that and we'll go through it
it's
one of the most um
i mean the
strangest weirdest where you're meeting
a wall
and the wall is not logical the
president of the united states is not
logical
i mean he's denying reality to you and
thinking that he's going to convince you
of something that's not true basically i
think
one of the things that i thought was
interesting is i think was jared kushner
in your book
talked about us but he he said there
were four texts you needed to read in
order to understand trump right and one
of them is a book
that is uh and maybe you can tell people
about this it's about
it's it's basically
about
using disinformation and lying
purposefully it's not that he's lying or
saying something that's false
without knowing it it's it's a strategy
and that's what this book is about it's
about you you you
wrong information you use it scott adams
book uh mr bigly where
persuasion in a world where facts don't
matter and he's recommending this as a
text to understand
his father-in-law the president of the
united states but kushner extracts a
little motto
from this and that is
controversy elevates message
means if there's a controversy and
basically you're telling the truth or
enough of the truth a discussion about
it will elevate your message
besides the example of trump going on
saying the best economy in the world
in all of history
going back to the roman empire or
something i mean it's just you know
that's the way it is and kushner says
okay
everyone knows literally that's not true
that in the 50s the economy was better
or sometimes
uh
and then all the fact checkers will come
around and they'll sound like they're
nitpicking and talking about something
and the average person kushner says
looks around says well
the economy is really quite good this is
before the virus and everyone attacking
the president is unfair
and uh
the controversy elevates message we are
now walking into the issue
of
the new supreme court justice that the
president is going to appoint
take that controversy boy is there going
to be controversy about it it elevates
message
for trump
and what's the message well i'm trying
to
get a put a supreme court justice in
who has impeccable credentials somebody
who
if it turns out
uh to be the cuban american
judge from florida or whoever it is he's
going to be able to say see
evangelical c people i'm fighting for
you i'm doing this for you i'm doing
what i believe in and
the controversy elevates message it's
perfect it's it outplays the press i
think in that we always are drawn to the
controversy and he creates the
controversy by lying on a subject he
wants to talk about and then we're all
drawn in to have to talk about the
subject he wants to talk about i mean i
thought it was really a pretty neat
description of this technique of of sort
of purposeful lying and and how it how
it works and that he you know it's not
it's not an accident basically i've got
it what kushner would say
it's not purposeful line it's purposeful
exaggeration you just take what uh
the old editor at the washington post
ben bradley is to talk about the extra
squeeze you have something that's good
and you take an extra squeeze and
overstate it and
that is a policy and it's operative
and in many ways it works
it while we're talking about
about
things about how you you made decisions
on what to say and do in the book i have
to ask you i i went on twitter and asked
people what would you ask bob woodward
and one of the questions that people
keep asking is why did you decide not to
um
tell the public
about
how much trump knew and when he knew it
about the pandemic um and how serious
the threat was about the coronavirus and
i know this is this is a perennial
question when you're working on
long-range stories people always say why
didn't he tell us earlier so maybe you
can tell people why did you not tell
everyone earlier but because i thought
trump was talking about china because
that was the only issue in february and
then in march when
the the pandemic exploded uh if
that knowledge
ev everyone had it what sort of story
would i write and i was looking at the
question uh and as you lost your sound
one sec oh okay there here you are
okay so so so basically what by the time
you you
uh my internet connection is unstable it
goes right through here there's no
microphone okay excuse me
did you think you might have answered it
even if i didn't hear um no no i i that
in february
everything was about china i thought
that's what he was talking about uh as
we know we all live our lives in
chronological order we don't report in
chronological order and it was not until
may i learned
how trump got that knowledge which was
critical and that's that january 28th
meeting which is the key event in all of
this uh and and by may the
the virus was totally out of control so
it's um
i didn't
i didn't see it i mean you could bring
elsa and my two assistants and they
could take an oath we never sat around
and said oh
is there something we should tell the
public here i've often
while i'm doing books break away and do
stories for the post uh
regularly if there's any reason i have
access to
uh the editor
marty barron on and it
because
we thought we're talking about
china and
that was the issue the virus was out of
control
and
being transmitted through the air in
china
and
so
you know that's how it i think it's a
fair question i think
i have
public safety public health
responsibility as a journalist if you
learn something is going to happen
uh you
have an obligation to
report it and in this case also i wasn't
sure whether it was true because trump
occasionally very occasionally says
things that don't check out
um i i was curious as a reporter about
whether you will at some point release
all the tapes of his interviews um the
the interviews you did with him it's is
something like nine hours of them is
that right yes
um i'm
releasing them selectively uh and like
the issue of the court and the judges
and so forth i'm going to release in a
few minutes from now uh on cnn and the
washington post and uh people can hear
what trump has to say about mcconnell
and how they're looking at the world and
they're it's it's quite a series of
transcripts and audios and you'll see
what
this really matters to trump
this issue of the court he realizes
it's
part of his legacy he would like to make
it more and more of his legacy
and he understands numbers and when i
interviewed him in the oval office he
had the nice parchment
the stack of appointments for the new
judges there and he was kind of
holding it is
something sacred and he had a picture of
kim jong-un big picture that he gave me
and uh
a binder with the letters between
kim jong-un and himself at that at that
point
do you think he has a judicial
philosophy or in fact
um policy
interests that are
consistent i i wondered in reading the
book it seems he talks a lot about how
important it is to be flexible which in
another way kind of means changing his
mind backwards and forwards on things do
you think
seems like maybe one of the other things
that he seemed quite fixated on was
making sure that he had negated all of
obama's policies is that his major
public you know consistent policy
direction or does he have policy
interests and a judicial philosophy
well i think it's transactional and
it's the impulse hey wait a minute you
know i'll go into the grocery store i'll
take the green one i'll take this and he
does see this is what drove
uh senior people who served him early
like
james mattis as defense secretary
tillerson as secretary of state dan
coats is the number one
intelligence person there was no
planning there was no organization there
was no let's all get together and decide
what we're going to do trump decided
it on his own and it finally the the
alienation these people who get you know
they were all
heading for retirement dan coats
director of
national intelligence had been a
republican senator from indiana for 16
years
a very close friend
with mike pence uh who became the vice
president and when pence was vice
president-elect he called coats up and
he said uh you want a job and coach said
no i don't want a job we're
he and his wife are retiring and then he
said well come meet with the
president-elect he met
with trump and
they offered him
number one intelligence job and they
thought
he and his wife marcia thought well
you know you have to do this and
maybe it's part of their very
religious
evangelicals and maybe this is part of
god's plan for us
well do you think we should try taking
some questions from the audience yes
what's going on out there okay bob well
thank you so much um
let me see if i can figure this out okay
um what are people asking um
can you see the questions as well or you
want me to just like okay
um
why do you think that trump was willing
to put himself on tape with such
incriminating information contradictory
to what he was saying in public
i'm yeah i think it it kind of just
became part of
his day or his week we would talk i
wasn't writing stories
and
as you know jane when you have
time to think and plan i could say okay
what's going on
in the world that i want to ask him
about for instance
may 25th george floyd was killed set off
a
an awareness of
race relations and
um
i and so i was able to ask trump and i
said you're a man of white privilege i'm
a man of white privilege also my father
was a judge and a lawyer in illinois do
you
understand the pain and anger that black
people feel
and this is on tape and it's in this out
and he just
wow bob you sure drank the kool-aid
i don't feel that at all it just mocked
me
for
and so you could see
uh in this case in dozens of other cases
i believe what he really felt
um
here's another question trump's often
highly critical of the news media
outlets that are not explicitly aligned
with his views how did you get trump to
speak so candidly to you
about what he knew about the coronavirus
in early days and it's it's related to
this again and i have to add one little
bit to this question
as a fellow reporter
i heard way back that you had a special
time when you thought it was best to
approach people to to interview them it
was an hour like maybe right before
dinner when you might they might have
poured themselves a drink and be
loosening up a little bit now i know the
president doesn't drink and i don't
seems like he was calling you at later
hours but
what is the woodward technique that gets
people to just plain
own themselves as the president did with
you
you know what you have to do it one of
the things you know this so well jane
everywhere but particularly in
washington everyone takes themselves
very seriously right is that true
and what when you're talking and
interviewing somebody you have to take
them
as seriously as they take themselves and
so you want to ask open-ended questions
you want to follow up you never
do like some reporters they'll have an
interview set up at 11 o'clock and one
at 12 and one at one i always leave
optimistically four hours on the end of
an interview so it can go as long and
rarely do they go four hours but
sometimes they do
but it creates a not a sense of oh i've
gotta go someplace i've got to do
something and i think you communicate
that to the person you're interviewing
and and often they're
quite willing to
engage you need to think you need to
follow up you need to
we'll release some of these tapes about
the supreme court i mean it's it's
it's
pretty amazing stuff
it's not stuff that trump would go say
uh
out
by the helicopter or in the oval office
and i think he grew comfortable with it
and he said a number of times said well
you're asking good questions these are
good questions i like
i like to
hear what
you're inquiring about and it often
overlapped converged with the news of
the day
do you think it played into his his
people have often described him as a
narcissist um
in that he loves to talk about and think
about himself did you find that to be
true of him
see happily i'm not a psychiatrist i
don't have to say this person is a
narcissist this is not uh i the the
slate the psychiatric slate is blank as
far as i'm concerned and uh so i don't
think that way i'm not working that way
what i'm working
toward is getting
a as straight and detailed and answered
as possible
here's a question um that is um
about a very specific thing you
a piece of news you had in your book
what do you make of the president's talk
about a powerful new weapon in the book
you say you couldn't confirm it since
then you have you gained any insight
into what it is yes i mean he said just
out of the blue he has a new nuclear
weapon that even
putin and chinese president xi don't
know about and it's the most destructive
thing in the world and so forth
i asked people about it some people said
yes they know
of such a weapon that's on the drawing
board but not
part of the arsenal yet somebody else a
couple of people thought no there is
something
uh and and so it's one of the mysteries
one of the trump mysteries that quite
frankly i could not answer in the book
people
i asked and they said oh yes it exists
but we can't talk about it kind of
mysteriously
some experts i've talked to since say
there's no such weapon
so
god um i i'm i'm curious if anything if
you found him to be
surprising in any way or different from
what you were expecting
um you know you don't i i don't bring
an extra an expectation because again i
think that can be a barrier to opening
somebody up is he different from the
picture the media has painted oh sure
absolutely
well and he he would let me
repeatedly go at him and say now wait a
minute what's going on here on april 5th
i spent a long time i've done reporting
on how do you deal with the virus
and
i had a dozen areas like testing
international coordination
and i went through them one by one with
him as and you know i think you have you
thought about this people i've talked to
and uh we went through all 12 of them
and he said
did you write those down and i said yes
we go over them again
as if he was going to write them down or
he had someone in the room writing them
down
and
my wife elsa was listening because it
was on the speaker phone and she said it
sounds like you're telling the president
what to do
and i'm not trying to tell him what to
do i'm trying to tell him what my
reporting shows
and the bottom line summation of it is
we need full mobilization
people want to know
that it's a kind of a manhattan
project like roosevelt had
that led to the atomic bomb and when
roosevelt i mean it's a famous moment in
history 1939
albert einstein
wrote
roosevelt a private letter saying
we in all the this business of uranium
and
so forth and einstein was just getting
going on this at this point and said
somebody could make a bomb
a devastating
bomb
and
what roosevelt do he didn't say oh i
don't want to panic people he told the
nade
action now
and set up
the manhattan project
and six years later
that was realized and the first atomic
bomb was exploded
in over hiroshima
and uh you know lots of debate did
truman do the right thing
did it shorten the war and so forth but
what roosevelt did in that case is
prepared the nation
and said action now
trump what was it no
let's not panic
and
did
it seems like you were having
conversations with him where you were
pushing back in ways that maybe his own
advisors didn't
do you feel he's kind of
isolated i i think he's isolated
by his own
lack of curiosity and lack of
organization
lack of intellectual stamina you know
it's hard oh i've got to make this
decision
ask six people what they think or three
or one and so often he won't ask anyone
he'll just do it he'll just tweet it out
and
it's we we need to be reminded and um so
and this is a
partisan this is
out of
the facts that are on the table
the virus
is a moving train
now a
thousand people are dying today as i was
saying it's live the experts say it's
going to get worse
that we could have
a
convergence with the regular flu
and you know god knows what we're
going to be presented with in the in the
coming months and we have a leader
who
like a mask i mean there's robert
redfield the head of the cdc saying
under oath
i know redfield he's a devout catholic
he's somebody who's
devoted his life to protecting the
united states
from
pandemics and
health crises and he's up there under
oath this week telling congress
wear a mask in fact it may be the more
important than the vaccine
and
then
trump hears about this
and
at a press conference he says well i
called
redfield and redfield was confused
didn't know what he was saying
and i mean
god help us
god help us if you have the president of
the united states calling the doctor and
saying oh i didn't like your diagnosis
it doesn't fit
my
political or whatever is going through
my head moment and to i mean i i just as
you know you followed up
people piled on saying redfield's not a
guy who is going to say something that
is not medically supported and sound
and trump still won't
put out a mass order trump will not even
let
the probably the world's expert on this
issue
robert redfield tell the congress under
oath what he thinks without trying to
to
restate it and call him up and and then
to say he was confused that
i don't want to use the word
but
but the word is
that is
outrageous behavior that you know you
know we always talk and i have talks
with trump about this you're in charge
of the
national interest you
this is a leadership moment for you and
he would say well no and i'd say look
the virus is
what the election's going to be about
of course not now this was a couple of
months ago
sorry to interrupt because we could go
on but it's eight o'clock and we've got
to get you to the release
of the tapes um thank you both bob and
jay
thank you so much so fast
getting a little worked up about this as
you may have noticed i can tell to
everyone watching thanks again for
tuning in from all of us here at
politics and pros stay well
and well read
thank you
jay dolan sunday night at 8 pm eastern
on c-span's q a
washington journal continues
joining us now is bob woodward author of
the new book rage and washington post
associate editor mr woodward i want to
begin with the headline in your
newspaper trump will not commit to
peaceful transition give us your insight
after writing two books about the
president on his comments yesterday
well it's it
it makes no sense for uh for anybody
even him but of course he thinks he can
bully his way through on this and
uh
the information i have it it's going to
be just a train wreck upon a train wreck
at election or after election time uh
how do you count the votes uh how do you
make sure that there is a fair and
square election
uh
we're we're
heading into
another chapter chapter 73 of
trump world and
we're just going to have to watch it
day by day hour by hour
you spoke with the president i believe
19 times for this book how did it come
about and how did he agree to
talk with you
well i did a book in 2018 fear on his
first two years and
he did not cooperate i tried to talk to
him
he regretted it he of course denounced
the book
said i was a democratic operative some
people close to him said oh by the way
the book is true
and so the president when i wanted to do
the second book said he would cooperate
i went into the oval office put my
little tape recorder down
on the resolute desk and said it's all
on the record i'm going to record it all
and
the book will come out in september or
october before the election and so he i
talked to him for nine hours and 41
minutes he would call me at home
at 10 o'clock or on the weekends or i
could call i had a number where i could
contact him so
it's
i guess what i would call a total
universe
portrait of he
his thinking about his job
the uh central issue of the virus
race relations the economy the supreme
court
we were able to
go down
every
avenue of
america i mean it's really a
look at him
and
he allowed me to push him and come back
to questions and
i i suspect he's not very happy now but
that's what he said
and that's what i was able to find out
from my other reporting what role did
senator lindsey graham have in the
president speaking to you
apparently he told the president look he
won't put words in your mouth you'll get
a straight shot last week the president
said hey i said some great things
in those interviews and on the book
in the book i let him have his say
entirely
so uh it's
it's as close
i believe having done this now for 50
years
that you can ever come to
uh as an outsider what's what was really
going on in the white house and the
administration
on
every matter
of importance
this is your 20th book mr woodward how
do you know when these former officials
are ready to talk
well
you you just keep
uh the old way used to be
go to their homes and knock on the door
at night
with the virus you can't do it so you
use the
telephone as your entree and people are
home at night and you can get them on
the phone sometimes sometimes
for extended periods of time sometimes
for
a very very long interviews a central
lesson for me
is people like to talk thank god i think
that
people are
out there
no matter what their politics their
secret shares
in believer as believers in the first
amendment
we want to invite our viewers to join in
on the conversation if you're supporting
joe biden and senator harris dial in at
202 748 8000 you're supporting president
trump and vice president pence
202-748-8001
if you're undecided or support others
202-748-8000
mr woodward you write in the book in
your author's note that evelyn duffy
insisted that everyone in this book get
the fairest truth impossible including
president trump she kept her eyes on
that prize and worked tirelessly to see
it fulfilled steve riley insists on
verification for everything no fact or
nuance goes unchecked tell us about this
process
uh they're my two assistants
who to i mean they were willing to come
to my house and work in their offices on
my third floor
i have an office on that floor my wife
elsa walsh has an office in the tower we
were a team working together
wearing masks being as careful as we
could exchanging drafts
doing
transcripts of all the interviews
with trump and with everyone else
elsa
we didn't have to wear a mask
with each other and we lived our lives
but we lived in that bubble of trump
world for
10 weeks
for both elsa and myself an
extraordinary time because
we could get
not only to trump but we could get to
other people in the white house cabinet
officers people close
to the president
sophia is up first in the bronx
supporting the former vice president
sophia go ahead you're on the air with
mr woodward
thank you
thank you mr woodward
are you there
yes i am
okay
i want to say this
15 years the job
you done
this one
you must get a nobel prize because
if you did not record him
he would have deny sir i voted for him i
am one of the deportable
i see now the last three weeks
the run he had
all the people my people
gathering each other month-to-month
he don't feel anything for them he don't
feel anything for us
even though he admitted
a new interview sir
that this is going to be bad
you understand sir and i turn to
i hope you get the nobel prize
because
somebody has to make it clear that you
are brilliant if you did not record him
we would have been he would have denied
it would have been chaos and thank you
for listening and i hope you stop about
the rally he's he's gonna kill us
he's gonna kill us sir and i supported
him i'm deportable sir okay sophia all
right mr woodward
okay
um i mean
first of all i recorded him with his
permission uh frankly
when the book came out
i wasn't sure i would put out the audios
my wife elsa walsh
jamie gangale at cnn who got the book
early they said
you need to put out audios and i've i've
done that a couple of times on books but
only in a small way
and they said no
it was kind of a pincer movement between
elsa and jamie to say no you've got to
do this
the context
was which
we know people don't trust the media
people don't trust
much and so
being able to hear it
in
with their own ears hear president trump
say these things
say to me that hey look he's trying to
downplay the virus he doesn't want to
cause a payment a panic
the key
to all of this and it i start my book
with this meeting on january 28th in the
oval office when the national security
team
the advisor robert o'brien told
president trump about the virus said
this virus is going to be
the biggest not maybe will be
is going to be the biggest national
security threat to your presidency
his deputy matt pottinger who had worked
in china
as a wall street journal reporter during
the
2003 pandemic knew that the chinese
government lied
all the time he had sources in china and
he was able to explain to president
trump not that just trouble was coming
but a major pandemic was coming because
he had those
contacts those sources in china in the
medical community who would stand up to
the chinese communist party and the
chinese government and
he said this is going to be
like the
1918
1918
spanish flu pandemic that killed 675
000 people in this country
carol royal oak michigan sporting the
president good morning carol hi
good morning hi i'm curious uh mr
woodward
do you like the president as a person
allow you
to do what you did you know
the president said go ahead turn the
machine on
do you think you'd ever get a democrat
to do that
all right carol
yes i i i have
many many times president obama
president
clinton
[Music]
so
it's it's a non-partisan tape recorder
if i may say that
and my approach is
aggressively nonpartisan you asked a
very good question at the beginning do i
like the president
he has
as you know he can be very charming he
would let me push him
we would
sometimes even joke about things but he
knew and i knew this is not a
a joking matter everything particularly
the virus and so
he has an appeal my wife elsa walsh says
well you know she listened in on some of
these calls because i would put it on a
speaker phone i told president trump
that
there was some
foul language and at one point president
trump
said i don't want your wife
uh to hear
this her pretty years i think was his
term so
i was i was open
in listening to him we started
these interviews before the virus
we talked a great deal about his
relationship with north korea and kim
jong-un the north korean leader
and i got the letters uh ex the letter
exchange between them and president
trump told me said look we've not had a
war
uh and there was an expectation maybe we
were going to have a nuclear war with
north korea and
i i think and i indeed give him credit
on this uh not having a war
i
back in the 1960s after i got out of
college i served five years in the
u.s navy
as communications officer
and this was during vietnam
i saw vietnam up close
and the lies of vietnam
and
the horror of that war and so i give
president trump credit for avoiding a
war with north korea at the same time
relations between trump and kim jong-un
have broken down now we don't know where
it's going lots of experts say they
don't think trump handled it right
i'm
agnostic on that i say this is what he
did and uh he's very emphatic with me in
these interviews that it was a no war
strategy
and if you look over
all at the trump administration
we've not had a new war and a lot of
people expected we
would have one at the same time
the relations with some countries
trump likes autocratic leaders
he talked to me about that quite openly
and so he's picked
leaders like putin
to have a good relationship with him
with mbs the crown prince of saudi
arabia and his negotiation with kim
jong-un anyway the the positives and the
negatives are
laid out as best i could
you write in the book about these
letters between the north korea leader
and the president which he calls love
letters you say the cia never figured
out conclusively who wrote and crafted
kim's letters to trump they were
masterpieces the analysts marveled at
the skill someone brought to finding the
exact mixture of flattery while
appealing to trump's sense of
grandiosity and being center stage in
history
the letters are magnificent because
there is a from kim jong-un he he just
reaches out for trump he said you know
we know each other we can trust each
other we're going to be friends for each
other at
one point
he talks about i remember
standing
meeting with you
holding your excellency's hand
and uh they pledge fieldy to each other
as i say in the
in the book it's it's almost like the
knights of the round table
and
at the same time
when kim jong-un would not deliver on
his agreement
to
get rid of his nuclear weapons
trump pushed him and said now look you
you gave your word on this
you're not ready to make a deal and so
the second meeting which was in hanoi
vietnam
kind of
fell apart we don't know where all of
this is going
it's a very dicey situation
because as
i report
kim jong-un has dozens several dozens
of nuclear weapons
uh they're probably
not uh you know big
big busters
like some of the missile
some of the
weapons that we have on our ballistic
missile submarines but they're nuclear
weapons and they're well concealed and
well hidden and
so it is a very real threat that we face
from them now
history is going to
determine
because as karl rove who was uh
george w bush's political adviser i
remember once told me for one of my bush
books i went up to see him in the white
house and rove said we're talking about
the iraq war and
the afghan war and other
issues and rove said look everything
depends on outcomes in politics and i
think that's true
the outcome of the relationship with
north korea we don't know where it's
going to end
let's go to carl who's in oxford
massachusetts and undecided in this
election go ahead carl
uh good morning thank you for c-span uh
mr woodward i i've seen you many times
on television
interviews i read one of your books a
long time ago i i forget the title of it
but i'm sorry to say i lost a lot of
respect for you after the
when the iraq war started
right after it started uh
many people realized it was based on the
lie and you kind of
came out like a couple of years later
with the book about that
uh i think you were on msnbc if i'm not
if i remember correctly and and to me
you were just to johnny come lately i
mean i'm i'm you know correct me if i'm
wrong but that's that's how i feel
well uh
look uh i wrote a story for the
washington post before the iraq war
started
and
which i
quoted a cia official saying they do not
have smoking gun intelligence that iraq
has
weapons of mass destruction
the government and the cia believed
that they did but this official told me
we don't have smoking gun intelligence
and i have faulted myself
mightily for not understanding what i
wrote in my own newspaper because when
somebody says
we don't have smoking gun intelligence
that means they don't have
verifiable information
they're not sure
and i
quite frankly should have realized what
i wrote
but i wrote a number of books about
the iraq war the third one was called
state of denial
in which i reported
with documentation in
all kinds of
interviews that
president bush george w bush at the time
was not telling the truth to the
american people about how bad
the situation was in iraq
it had deteriorated in the years after
the 2003
invasion
christopher
go ahead mr woodward finish up
no i was just going to say
the iraq war was really an important
turning point
i've
always said i should i've been more
aggressive about it but i did
report what happened internally in the
significantly
the cia director george tenet went to
make a presentation to president bush
about
whether there are weapons of mass
destruction and the president president
bush kind of
was doubted
that the intelligence was
that solid
and george tenet stood up in the oval
office and said it's a slam dunk mr
president
it is a slam dunk and so that was the
view
at the highest level
in the cia as you may recall
colin powell then secretary of state
gave that famous
speech at the united nations in which he
held up a little bottle and said you
know this uh contains
uh
a chemical weapon
and this is what a iraq has powell has
since said it is his most
embarrassing his worst moment
in
his tenure not only as a military
officer but as secretary of state so
i
i should have been more aggressive i
should have been
quite frankly
in that story i cited in the washington
post i should have
understood when you don't have smoking
gun intelligence
you don't you're not sure and you're
going to go to war on that basis
anyway
all right we'll go on to christopher in
oklahoma supporting the biden harris
ticket go ahead christopher
okay uh good morning to you both and
massive respect for
just
the washington journal in and of itself
for us to be able to do this
last thing i thought i'd be doing this
morning is asking bob woodward a
question
okay um
there's been
we know 200 over 200 000 deaths from
covet 19 uh
i i want to know
personally
uh do you feel
like any responsibility
for
publicly withholding the information
that donald trump initially disclosed to
you early on about the virus
like
even later on
um
after it got time to for your book to
come out
but also
in those initial periods
when he was telling you one thing
and then turning right around a week or
two later on tv telling all of us the
exact opposite mr woodward
okay
it's a fair question and uh when trump
told me on february 7th
that he knew the virus was airborne and
that it could be transmitted from
somebody who had
who didn't have symptoms
and that it was
deadly in fact more deadly than the flu
we were talking about
china and he had just the evening before
had a talk with president xi and i
brought a stack
of newspaper clippings from the my
newspaper the washington post and the
new york times and all through
the the period of january and february
they were talking about china i thought
trump was talking about china and it was
not until may
that i learned that trump had been
briefed and that the centerpiece of this
is january 28th when trump was told by
his national security advisors
that the virus as robert o'brien put it
to the president is going to be
not as i say maybe but is going to be
the biggest national security threat to
your presidency and his deputy matt
pottinger laid out
information that pattinger head from
doctors in in china
and i did not know about that meeting
until may
and uh what's what's interesting about
journalism
obviously
reporters like
you
sir
we live our lives in chronological order
but you don't report in chronological
order and if i had known
what i
learned in may
i obviously would have gone and
published a story but i did not know
where that was coming from in the
context
of my discussion with president trump is
china and then when i learned ah he's
talking about what he was presented
in on january 28th and
i learned that by asking in may
president trump do you remember
that january 28th meeting and president
trump said no
he didn't but then he said twice he said
i'm sure it was said i
am sure
it was said by
that he got that warning from
o'brien and and pottinger so
by may even by march the virus was out
of control everyone knew it was deadly
my god in march
all of a sudden it it just came to this
country in a way exactly that the
president was told but came to this
country there were 30 000 new cases a
day
i was traveling around in early march
going to california going to florida i
had no idea
tony fauci who was the leading
infectious disease
official in this country well known on
television
was saying on
february 29th oh go ahead there's no
worry go to the mall
go to the movies go to the gym so
there was no way for me i had no
information
that that's what trump was talking about
when i you walked the cat back
and after i learned in may i realized
and i asked the president was that where
you got that information and he said yes
he knows he knows it was said
by o'brien it sounds like a convoluted
explanation but that's exactly what
happened and
i still work at the washington post as
an associate editor i have
access to the editor marty barron to
walk into his office or call him or
email him and say i have information
that needs to go in the paper
over the decades i've done that dozens
and dozens of times and i would have
done it
in this case but i did not understand
what trump was talking about and it
if you go back and you look
look at these clips
every one of them
in
january and february is about
china
because that's where i mean at one point
there was a front page story in the new
york times saying
china because of the virus locked down
wuhan where it started but
many other cities in china
locked down and when the chinese
government locks down
you go to your apartment and you're
locked in it
at 768
million people
that's twice the population of the
united states
and
all the discussion all the focus was on
china including
by me of course trump had participated
in that critical january 28th meeting
and uh
that is the day
the trump presidency should have changed
he should have realized what was coming
actually he did
and
when he gave his state of the union
address a couple of days later
he you know this is to the congress it's
about
what's going on in the world as he sees
it what's important what's the future
going to be like
50 i'm sorry 40 million people watched
that speech he devoted 15 seconds to the
virus saying we're doing everything we
can
he was not doing everything he he could
he was he could have told
the
country the truth about what he had
learned on january 28th
he could have protected the people
he could have
fulfilled his duty
as president unfortunately he didn't we
now have over two hundred thousand
deaths
from that virus in this country
and this
year ago if we were talking and i said
oh we're going to have
a pandemic that will kill 200 000 people
you would think i was on
some
uh
drug of some sort but that's exactly
what has happened
he could have mitigated that he could
have used his knowledge and as he told
me and we've played this audio said oh i
always like to play it down i like to
play it down because he didn't want to
create a panic
the sad
element in all of this is that president
trump did not understand
the people he leads
people in this country democrats
republicans independents undecided
people who don't vote
have one
thing in common and that is when they're
told the truth
they rally around
they
step up they do what is necessary to
deal with the problem
americans don't panic maybe some people
will but by and large and i if
i may bore you a little bit with
history because history can tell us a
lot in this case
my wife elsa walsh we would go through
all the information we were getting from
trump and other people as i was writing
this book and she was editing it six
times
and we sat at dinner one night
and she said well what should trump have
done what's the remedy
and she looked into history and franklin
roosevelt's famous fireside chats
after
a one crisis or another and go back and
listen i mean they will bring it will
bring tears to your eyes if you listen
to roosevelt talking
two days
after pearl harbor
after the japanese sneak attack on pearl
harbor and
two days later
president
roosevelt comes on in this fireside chat
and says
it's all bad news
the most serious undertaking of our
american history is before us the very
survival
of our country in the world is at stake
it is going to be for every american
citizen grueling work day night every
hour
every minute
and then he said government
our government
his government
has confidence in your ability to hear
the worst
without losing heart
president trump instead instead
approached this and said well i better
not
tell the truth i better play it down
because
people might panic
i know one thing from doing this
for 50 years
uh people in this country don't panic
people uh in this country are strong
sorry to go so long but it's relevant
we'll go to carolyn who's in austell
georgia supporting the president hi
carolyn
good morning
uh
president trump is doing a very good job
and we can make a whole list of all the
good things that he's done
and um i know that we have a lot of
books coming out and that president
trump seems to uh trust a lot of his
bank staffers with information coming
out now i have it's going to take me
another minute
well a minute to finish up body seems to
have a poor sense of well-being
and i just want to know
if after two years and maybe this is
something that we need to know after two
years will harris become our first woman
president
and the last question i have is for c
spain
the plague always killed people which we
hate
but c-span it would be good if they
could have something
on
the
death rate in this country my
understanding from reading is that we
lose about 7 000 people daily
you know they just died daily okay
all right understood carolyn mr woodward
can we we've talked about the
president's handling of the coronavirus
you also talked to him about the
impeachment proceedings and at one point
you are questioning him uh about
whether or not he should apologize and
you ask him
who does who is in the world is the
person that he trusts the most explain
his answer
well i did i did but in this was in the
context this was down at mar-a-lago
before the virus became an issue it was
the end i think it was december 30th of
last year
and
trump was
his impeachment trial in the senate was
going on so i was able to ask him
about this and it's very clear from the
transcript of his discussion with the
ukrainian president
that
trump was asking the ukrainian president
to talk to attorney general barr
about
the bidens and
what the bidens were doing in ukraine
and i kept pressing
the president said do you think it's a
good policy
for the president of the united states
to be able or to ask foreign leaders to
investigate political opponents
president kept insisting
that
it was all about corruption and i said
well here's the transcript you released
your own
words
and uh
we got
it it was pretty contentious because i
kept going back to what was in the
transcript he released i said you gave
like richard nixon when nixon
tape recorded his secret conversations
you gave the opposition a sword and
trump didn't believe this and we started
talking more about nixon and i said look
if nixon
a few months
after watergate had come out and said
you know
this is
illegal
people did things i'm responsible
i apologize to the country i apologize
to the democratic
national committee and where they had
the offices that
the burglars broke into
and
just kind of laid it out
in a soulful way now nixon
was not that soulful but if if he had
done this if he'd apologized and trump
agreed oh yeah if nixon
apologized uh watergate would have gone
away and i said okay on this if you
apologize
and
he said oh i'd never apologize and
i didn't do anything wrong i said well
we went back to is this a good policy
and
i said take ivanka your daughter walk on
this
beautiful property down
here that you have mar-a-lago and and
have a
father-daughter talk and ask her if she
would recommend that you apologize and
he said i'm not going to do that it
wouldn't make any difference of what
she said i think it wasn't going to make
any difference what
anyone said and this is part of the
problem
with trump as president he gets things
in his head and he will not get them out
he will not listen to others they have
no process
he uh as i go through an extensive
detail in the book what his national
security team
of
uh jim mattis defense secretary
tillerson the secretary of defense dan
coats the director of national
intelligence that they can't get through
to him he won't listen there's
it
it's tragic and it's particularly tragic
in the context of the virus
and the 200 000 people in this country
who died and by telling the truth
the president could have averted some of
those deaths
norman in amherst massachusetts norman
go ahead the house is gaveling in early
this morning at 9 00 a.m so i need a
quick question
hi uh yeah thanks senator thank you i
studied your work when i was in
journalism school in the mid to late 70s
uh
what i'm worried about the future of
freedom in the press uh
as in the julian assange case uh what do
you think would happen under under trump
and would it be different
under biden thank you
well um i'm always worried about freedom
in the press as i write in the book uh
trump always
accuses the press of being fake news and
so forth uh and attacks the the media
but uh he hasn't sent the the marshals
or fbi agents to break into reporters
homes or arrest them so my conclusion is
in this this is on a happy note that
democracy has held we still have a
democracy in this country now trump
often threatens it it's something to
worry about
deeply
but
the problem is and
we've had a leadership failure there is
a breakdown
in the leadership of this country
and uh
it is uh on on so many levels just a
practical level
a moral level a president has so much
authority they have to jim mattis says
trump does not have a moral compass
the president needs and has a
responsibility to the citizens of this
country and
unfortunately on so many
levels he's let us down
mr woodward will you write another book
well i'm 77 years old i
don't know
you have to see i didn't really think i
was going to write a second trump book
after doing the first one um so
so uh you know the
no no plan i'm gonna take a little time
off with my wife and we're gonna
enjoy some other things
when we during this 10 months of working
on the trump book
and
she editing it six times and so forth i
remember one night she said
because we talk about these things so
much and we were living them and my god
the phone would ring at 10 o'clock and
it'd be trump calling unexpectedly
and
i remember her saying
i need
one hour
away from trump
in trump world all right
mr woodward we appreciate your time the
book is rage come back
thank you
all right the house is gaveling in for
their morning legislative business early
this morning so we will take you there
live coverage right here on c-span
vision for serious readers
good evening everyone and welcome to pmp
live i'm brad graham the co-owner of
politics and pros along with my wife
elissa muscatine
we have a great program for you this
evening featuring washington post
journalists bob woodward and robert
costa here to talk about their
revelatory new book peril
covering the last months of the trump
administration and the first months of
biden's presidency
a couple of brief housekeeping notes
first though
to post a question at any point during
the discussion just click on the q a
icon at the bottom of the screen
in the chat column you'll find a link
for purchasing copies of peril
bob woodward of course has been
observing and reporting in washington
for half a century
in his five decades with the washington
post where he remains an associate
editor he's covered ten presidents and
shared two pulitzer prizes first for the
post coverage of the watergate scandal
and second as the lead reporter for
coverage of the 911 terrorist attacks
his books have made headlines and drawn
many readers apparel is his 21st book
all have been national bestsellers
bob costa's a little younger about half
woodward's age as woodward himself notes
in the acknowledgments
but uh
acosta already has made a name for
himself as national political reporter
at the post
where he's worked for nearly eight years
following several years at the national
review
he's also served as moderator and
managing editor of washington week on
pbs
and as a political analyst for nbc news
and
msnbc
no doubt many of you watching have heard
or read some of the highlights of peril
general milley's call for instance with
his chinese counterpart to ease chinese
fears about trump possibly launching an
attack or vice president mike pence is
searching for whether there indeed was
some way he and congress could reject
the election results only to be told by
none other than dan quayle to forget it
there's much more to this explosive page
turner of a book which reads like a
thriller and will leave you aghast not
only at how close the country came to
the brink but also how perilous the
future remains
in conversation with with the authors
will be gene robinson
pulitzer prize winning columnist at the
post who in his four decades with the
paper
also has covered city hall
reported from europe and south america
and then into the style section
additionally he's the author of three
books he's working on a fourth and
appears frequently on msnbc as a
political analyst
so gentlemen
screen is yours
thanks so much brad and it's i just
first want to say what a what a pleasure
and what an honor it is uh to be doing
this tonight um brad i've known you for
many years um uh you were my predecessor
of south america correspondent at the
post
um uh
bob costa
i've known you since you came to work at
the washington post and and very quickly
saw um
and admired your doggedness and
persistence as a reporter and the way
you worked your sources i said you know
this is this is a great this is a great
young reporter
and bob woodward um i i've known you for
41 and a half years you hired me at the
washington post uh and it will suffice
what a mistake
[Laughter]
well you can you can you can try to
atone for that if you want but it's too
late to take it back and uh you know it
will suffice to say that you are the
great reporter of our time
uh and it is uh so it is a real
privilege to be here with with the two
of you um to talk about peril and and so
my first question is about the making of
the book and so how did this
collaboration
come about um
bob woodward you have you've done other
books with collaborators you have done
co-authors you have done books
on your own
how did um what seems to have been a
match made in heaven
actually actually come about
it was actually a match made in
trump's hotel
in
washington in 2016.
costa said to me you know
trump might be president he was on the
verge of getting the nomination and
costa said we should go interview him so
we did
and um
i got two titles
from the interview uh when trump talked
about uh i always bring out fear or i
use fear
to
get my way and i bring out rage in
people so fear and rage came from that
interview
and then
after we had a afterwards after the
interview and trump was very
i mean he said some things
uh that didn't
come out it didn't actually happen for
instance he promised he would if he was
elected president he would end the
national debt
in
the first term
and uh as i observed that has not
happened in fact the national debt has
gone through the roof
uh in his four years as president and
and then uh
costa and i talked and bob you remember
what you said to me
well bob we had a several conversations
at the time about how we have to take
trump seriously but i really think
and bob woodward and i have discussed
this that that interview in 2016 was a
precursor to this book
in in particular in terms of the method
when i approached woodward and we said
hey let's talk go talk to this candidate
donald trump
he said let's just not go in there with
the fishing pole
as reporters and try to get different
sound bites let's prepare
really prepare for the interview and he
showed me some of these
documents that he has presented to other
presidential candidates and presidents
in the past and he said to me back in
2016 in february and march as we were
getting ready think about decisions why
did trump decide to run how does he want
to use power if he achieves and wins the
presidency how would he wield that power
does he understand it what does he want
what's his goal
and
in the heart of a campaign trump had
effectively sewn up the nomination in
march of 2016 we went in there to have a
governing conversation with donald trump
and trump even seemed at the time taken
aback by the interview which was quite
long
it was not
about really topics of the day it was
about the presidency
and that to me
was one of those moments where i sat
back as a reporter and said this method
this approach of really looking at the
governing possibilities first not the
political issues is critical and i said
to myself too we probably aren't doing
this enough uh as we cover this campaign
and woodward and i have remained close
since as reporters thinking through
these issues discussing the office of
the presidency power decisions
well it's fascinating you know as as i
read
peril over the last few days
um you know just pretty regularly my jaw
would drop as i could come across a
passage that i just say you know
whoa you know um i am
in in other words that i don't use in
polite company um uh just to describe
some of the stuff you guys fell out but
i found out but i'm curious and and um
um let's start with you on this bob
woodward and then
bob costa
what made your drop your jaw drop what
what
what was the the the revelation the the
nugget the
um the the event the conversation what
what was it that that just jumped out at
you and made you say whoa
well what uh the theme of what we found
and it truly surprised us that
uh this period between the election and
the inauguration of biden was a national
security crisis not just a domestic
crisis
and the worry that trump might
have a reichstag moment and oh what
would be the
domestic impact of that what we didn't
realize is that the chinese the russians
the iranians were watching the united
states
and
were terrified about what was going on
and put themselves on military alert in
fact
the chinese at one point
general lee the head of the chinese
military
was telling people and it was in the
intelligence reports he thought
the united states was going to attack
china and
when general milley chairman of the
joint chiefs
saw this this was a crisis because when
the adversary
thinks you might attack them
as millie told his senior staff then you
have to worry they may
attack you you may have a pearl harbor
and
if you put yourself in
millie's shoes as we tried to do with
our reporting of
how this all went down
it was uh a very dangerous time
and uh later
it's been said these were secret calls
phone calls he had
with general lee they were on a top
secret back channel but they were not
secret and uh the second call uh after
two days after the nine
i'm sorry the january sixth insurrection
he was
had intelligence that the chinese
thought
united states was collapsing and once
again he had to deal with general
lee
and uh he brought in the intelligence
agencies he uh the nsa national security
agency gina haspel the cia director and
told her
look at everything told the joint chiefs
called up the admiral who ran operations
around china and said
cancel the exercises because they may be
misread by the chinese is provocative so
these were not seen but this was a
moment
this is a
military person's
nightmare
and
to have an adversary think
you might attack them and then later
to have the adversary uh actually think
that you your own government might
collapse
that that's just astonishing um you you
guys write that during that time
um general milley was concerned that
that president trump had suffered a
serious
mental decline in the in the aftermath
of the election
and i'm curious i'd like both of you to
weigh in on this maybe starting with bob
costa um
why was this why was this that much of a
surprise the way trump was acting why
was this that much of a surprise to
milly at this at that point given
what he had seen from trump and all the
other sort of jaw-dropping moments that
we see
uh
that we learn of in in the book um um
rob
costa our reporting does not
cast it or show it to be a surprise it's
a culmination
it's a conclusion following months
of a general's assessments up close of
president trump going back to lafayette
square we have scenes in the book of
president trump screaming at military
leaders civilian and in uniform about
the protests in washington d.c and his
desire to bring combat troops into
washington dc to confront the protesters
we see
president trump issuing a
his own memo outside of the usual uh
channels to withdraw u.s troops from
afghanistan in november of 2020 a very
critical moment in the book because it
causes people like chairman milly to
realize this president could go outside
of the channel not only on withdrawal uh
when it comes to afghanistan and put his
black
uh sharpie signature
on some kind of document that it leads
to a situation with dire consequences
but that same kind of behavior that
conduct coupled with president trump's
anger and fury over his defeat
uh to biden could lead to
challenges to perhaps even a crisis or
catastrophe with the u.s nuclear arsenal
and that's why on january 8th
he calls in members of the nmcc uh the
brigadier generals the the colonels who
run the the strike operations the
pentagrams pentagon's war room and he
says follow the procedure and make sure
i'm part of this procedure i need to be
on the net bring me in if you get a call
from anybody
call me now milly's not in the chain of
command but he wants to be part of the
procedure and he's supposed to be part
of the procedure and he says to them
each
as he goes around the room got it yes
sir got it yes sir and it's quite a
moment because he is not a psychiatrist
but he's the senior military officer in
the united states making a conclusion
that the president he's seen up close is
in serious mental decline and he's also
getting the speaker of the house that
same day nancy pelosi calling him and
saying he's crazy speaking of president
trump and we have the whole transcript
in the book a transcript that's never
been revealed to the public before and
she's saying he's crazy you better make
sure
you have some control over this nuclear
arsenal so something that could trigger
war perhaps even war with china or
another adversary doesn't happen
yeah you know it's just um i guess i'm
asking because um
it's just certainly not the first crazy
we saw from trump or not the first crazy
we see i mean you know in
chronologically in the book i mean early
in the
trump administration we
we have him um uh uh refusing for a
while to sign off on an aircraft carrier
because he doesn't he doesn't quite like
the look of it you know he thinks that
the tower should be in a different
position
he's you know he's a naval architect all
of a sudden um uh and uh you have paul
ryan uh the former speaker of the house
um you know getting a briefing on
narcissistic personality disorder um uh
and you have to wonder um
you know how many people sort of knew
what they were dealing with uh when they
were dealing with
with with donald trump you mentioned um
the lafayette
square park on
debacle in in june of 2020 when um
you know the
peaceful demonstrators were cleared
violently
out of the area and the president
walked over to
saint john's church to hold up the bible
um millie uh
general milly went with him regretted it
later apologized for having gone
especially in his fatigues
um
afterwards um uh
secretary
um and then secretary of defense mark
esper did an interesting thing he um
um
having heard this
burbling about the use of the
possible use of the insurrection act
to mobilize
the military against
black lives matter demonstrators
esper
announced publicly announced that
there was no need to invoke the
insurrection act and uh and and
trump was furious he was furious and he
yelled at
that's where you're taking away my
authorities he would not be pushed
around and he said and he actually
shoved his statement at trump
who was sitting at the resolute desk you
know this is what i said understand
don't misinterpret it and
so this is one of the many incidents
where millie just said my god
there is a mental decline here there is
a danger
and he had a wonderful phrase for it uh
which i want to read so i don't screw
enough
for milly said this is the absolute
darkest moment of theoretical
possibility other words the moment was
dark but the possibility was theoretical
but then it became
real when you mix it with the trump
personality and this irrational
raging so what
esper
and billy realized
on this that they had actually
checkmated
anyone i mean
gene and i worked together for years i
mean there's a point where you checkmate
the boss you keep the boss from doing
what will be damaged to the institution
or even the boss and they believe
they've checkmated trump on bringing the
combat troops to washington so this is
the beginning of millie's experience in
esper's experience and they were working
in tandem
the problem esper had he was fired by
trump a few days after the election
and uh trump put in uh somebody who was
chris miller who was
no one knew what was going on
there
there was a lot of or there was no trust
in and so you have the moment after
moment i mean imagine i don't want to
dwell on this too much but here millie
is up in miller's office and sees this
memo that trump has signed withdraw all
the troops from afghanistan
uh milly head is
under the law is supposed to be involved
in this and he was not he was surprised
they go over to the white house and
eventually trump nullifies that memo but
clearly he will go trump will go offline
um
let me just
jump back to
to the actual events of of uh january 6
for a minute um uh because they continue
to reverberate and will continue to
reverberate uh in our politics and in
our national life i think for a long
time um and
and so this question for for bob costa
um
the west wing apparently was
more or less deserted that day there
were very few people there and from the
description in peril
the president seems almost
mesmerized or transfixed by the
television
interviews and almost out of it in a uh
in a sense is that an is that an unfair
characterization or how would you um bob
costa characterize
the reporting about
trump and inside the west wing on that
day
as bob woodward has said we have
discovered this national security crisis
a very grave situation on the national
security front during the transition
especially after the insurrection on
january 6. but we've also found a very
grave domestic political crisis that
bordered on being a constitutional
crisis if a few things had gone
differently
and while the events
in the west wing in the afternoon of
january 6 it was pretty deserted
president trump is watching tv in kind
of a flat mood it's not
accurate to think about that as
president trump in january 6. the most
some of it to me is a reporter some of
the most important parts of that section
of the book come in the days before
january 6 and while president trump may
have been watching tv and seemingly idle
during the riot itself we see president
trump through our reporting be a very
active player in the days before january
6th
on january 2nd senators like mike lee
and lindsey graham two top republicans
close allies are being pressured by the
white house mark meadows the chief of
staff rudy giuliani and john eastman
this conservative lawyer to think
through
how to help president trump get his aim
of throwing some of these electors out
moving the election to the house of
representatives where republicans
because they have control of the most
delegations could potentially tip the
election to president trump and a very
important meeting comes on january 4th
where vice president pence and his
lawyer and his advisors come in to the
oval office president trump is there
with john eastman this conservative
lawyer and for the first time we've
published this memo that has gotten a
lot of attention this week a six-part
memo from john eastman outlining how
pence could throw out electors and give
the election to trump and you see in
this scene president trump saying to
pence listen to john eastman listen to
john listen to john and eastman has this
memo saying it's constitutional and
legal for pence to essentially walk up
on january 6 and then walk away and so
this is president trump having a
pressure campaign of his own vice
president and using the legal
conservative community and his allies
there the political community allies on
the outside like giuliani and steve
bannon who were together on january 5th
all these things are happening behind
the scenes and that's what matters in
the reporting as much or probably more
than just president trump sitting there
on january 6 watching tv
that's fascinating let's talk a bit talk
for a minute about um
vice president pence um
whom um whom president trump urged to
you know the rebusing memo and he kept
talking about eastman and
he says it's legal he says you can do it
um ultimately um
the vice president
decides based on the legal advice he was
getting
um that no he couldn't just throw out
the um
the votes and and meanwhile i believe it
was senator um senator lee who had um
who had taken it on himself to call
the electoral election officials in some
of the states
and and learn that
none of the states
was going to toss out its electors
anyhow um but um
bob woodward talk a bit about pence
and how you came to view him after your
reporting was he
resolute throughout this crisis was he
tempted um perhaps to see what he could
do to to satisfy the president he had
served so loyally um for four years um
uh
and how you how do you and how should we
end up seeing him um
based on
on what what you guys find out
it's complicated and multi-dimensional
uh pence wanted to accommodate trump
because pence uh knew that if something
could be worked out here he might be
able to stay
as vice president he may it was so
obvious i mean there are the scenes
where uh
with which we can report for the first
time where
trump and pence are in the oval office
and
trump is saying to him
don't you wish you had this power
wouldn't it wouldn't this be great and
pence's
resisting but
he's back and forth and he had some
lawyers and counselors who were
identified uh in the book saying no you
can't do this you don't have the power
and
as you pointed out at one point pence
and dan quayle the former vice president
who
also it was it had been from
indiana
told pence said look you don't have that
power he actually cited the constitution
and the law but you see
a hesitation waltz on
pence's part in all of this finally at
the end he does stand up and do
what is constitutional and realizes uh
and
and says to advisers okay i'm gonna do
what
the conservative constitutionalists
would do but this was a this was part of
the peril in all of this that if pence
had gone
the other way
and decided i'm confused i don't know
how we certify
the winner here
and walked away
which he could have done and of course
trump
was very anxious to have him do we would
have had a constitutional crisis a
crisis about the legitimacy of the
presidency who's president who won and
so forth and so this again is one of the
uh political and constitutional bullets
that we dodged the whole time we did and
i mean it and it's it's almost funny to
say we dodged the bullet because then we
went through january 6th um and and
there are millions of americans who
still deny the legitimacy of the
election but in fact we did dodge a
larger caliber bullet that um that would
have been this
this absolute constitutional crisis if
pence had acted those conversations you
refer to the book quotes
president trump saying to his vice
president wouldn't it almost be cool to
have that power
um to to just throw out the votes and um
when pence says no um
trump says i don't want to be your
friend anymore if you don't do this
um and uh and he says you betrayed me i
made you you were nothing
it's all
about
donald trump isn't it isn't it i mean it
isn't everything
from the beginning to the end
every minute of every day isn't it all
about donald trump um and i use the
present tense because i assume it's
still that way is that what you found
from your reporter
uh
one thing that really stood out to us in
our reporting gene is after pence leaves
the oval office
he looks white as a ghost
rattled
people who were seeing him at that time
said he was shook and he goes home he
has his dinner schedule with donors that
night but president trump on january 5th
stays at the white house and he opens
the door
to the oval office out into the garden
it's 31 degrees outside and people are
all chair
getting ready for the rally ecstatic uh
this is the big moment
and at the willard hotel you have
giuliani and bannon and other trump
allies huddling together in their own
sort of war room and out in the streets
and i was in the streets of washington
that night reporting and it was it was
chaos cops fighting with protesters
protesters in red caps walking through
the streets
and what we found out is president trump
opens the door to the oval office in the
freezing weather
you know and takes it all in here's the
cries of his supporters
and says isn't that terrific and when
some of trump's aides come in the room
they start to shiver they say what is
going on is someone going to close the
door he doesn't close the door he keeps
it open he wants to hear
his people out there and bob
woodward said to me
it almost reminded him of nixon talking
to the pictures on the walls in 1974.
and and what's what's interesting about
it um and
bob costa and i talked about this at
length because when we discovered what
happened at this moment it's almost
a mystical engagement
that trump has with the mob out there
people and he's mesmerized by it and uh
we discussed this and when nixon
in his final days was talking to the
pictures on the wall nixon was talking
to washington
and lincoln
trump was talking to his mom
and those that is
his connection to
the population and uh it is
uh
the last lines in
the book are peril remains because trump
and
uh what he stands for
uh and uh
is out there in in the political world
now
uh some
some polls show that he would beat biden
he has 30 trump has 30 to 40 percent of
the people
believing that uh
the election was stolen from him when
you know the biggest trump supporters
lindsey graham and senator mike lee
investigated the charges and came up and
concluded it's zero
but trump won't listen to his own allies
who
investigate and say
there's nothing here
the um the book has um these
you know
dropping chapters about
about
trump and the in the final days of the
trump administration but it also has
chapters about um
joe biden and the incoming biden
administration
and
when you read you switch from one to the
other it's almost like you're talking
about two different countries right
you're talking about one country that's
where everything is crazy in one country
where things are more orderly and and
and normal and work the way you kind of
think
um government in washington works no
matter which party is in is in charge is
that a fair characterization of the
contrast that you get in the book in our
and and it isn't a book of
not just two um uh
fascinating individuals but but two
countries as well
uh i wouldn't phrase it particularly
that way uh with respect these are
intertwined stories and we begin the
book with the millie moment january 8th
and you understand where this country
ended up in the days after the
insurrection
but we also wanted to answer the
question in our reporting how did we get
there and where is this nation going and
so we go back to charlottesville back to
biden's decision to run someone who had
run twice before 88 2008 never really
found his footing in any of those races
in any meaningful way but he always had
this burning ambition even eight years
after being vice president
and he decided to run
spurred by this belief that what was
happening in the country white
supremacist march in central virginia
this was un-american and
his traditional
center-left democratic politics never
really caught fire but he
his ability to see democracy
at risk that fueled him in a different
way to almost feel like he was on a
mission
uh in the years of 2017 2018 2019 before
he made a formal decision to almost will
himself to run to try to confront what
trump in his mind was doing to the
country and it's a human story it's a
political story and it's a reaction
um
it's almost time to
start taking some some questions from
the audience um but before we do i have
just one um one quick question uh for
both of you
um and i'll start with bob costa and
then bob woodward is he running again is
trump going to run again he continues to
tease it publicly and says to everybody
he knows you're going to like my
decision
uh his confidants who are working with
him now or updating him on polling all
the time in new jersey in florida
telling him he's the most popular
republican in the country that he has
the political capital he's saying to
many people behind the scenes in our
book he wants to run again uh and he
tells brad parscale his former campaign
manager this past summer
he he wants that army back that's his
phrase he had an army he wants it back
and if he runs again parscall told
others privately he's going to run not
for any sort of policy aim but he's
going to run because he believes the
election was stolen and he wants
vengeance
i think
he's definitely
running
the really interesting question is why
what uh what is the rationale for the
candidacy gene as we used to talk about
you know why this candidate why
are they running uh what would they do
if they won
and
trump has based
his whole i mean all this year on this
issue the election was stolen
and
uh
he pivots around that and
i i think it's so important to examine
exactly
was the election stolen
bob costa and i spent months on this
question there is no evidence
and
when you have senators lindsey graham
and senators mike lee
investigate i mean here
there was a scene where
it's an extended scene where mike lee is
sitting because he reads this memo
from john eastman saying there's
alternative slates
of electors in seven states and
lee is going what i haven't heard that i
haven't seen that that would be major
news and a senator
can get anyone on the phone as we know
and he sits there for a couple of days
and calls all the heads of the
legislators in
arizona wisconsin pennsylvania and
georgia and says
alternative electors no
zero time and there's nothing there and
he tries to tell trump personally this
and convey that message as has lindsey
graham his supporters you know uh gene
uh you know it's kind of like at the
washington post when we're working on a
story and some editor says well the
story's there the in the reporter from
the field sometimes has to come in and
say no it's not there it doesn't not
there yet exist
and sometimes
these ideas that editors and presidents
have in their head
these things do not exist and the
existence of a stolen election
is a total fantasy
uh and i you know we scratched around we
called people we went out into the night
i mean this is old-time stuff knocking
on doors reluctant sources making sure
that we
got
the best obtainable version of what
occurred here and what occurred here is
there was no stolen election
right well um on that note
um i will um i'm gonna i'm gonna
turn to some of the questions we have
from the audience and so
um first one um now how would you
explain uh the overreaching of general
milley it seems that he stepped outside
the regular channels isn't this
considered
treasonous did billy in fact step
outside of any normal channels in his
communications with the chinese or or
was this within
um within his lane he has wide lane he's
the chairman of the joint chiefs but was
it within his lane
rob costa so
chairman millie is going to testify
before congress next week and
he has issued a statement ahead of that
testimony uh
saying that he worked within the
procedures uh to make sure that there
was not some kind of miscommunication as
bob and i write miscommunication can be
the seed of war milly knew that he
wanted to avoid it on october 30th 2020
that's why there was the call with
general lee and again on january 8
2021
and it's important to read
the full book because the full book has
the full context and the context shows
that in each of these moments in the
calls he was reading in other people he
was calling up gina haspel the cia
director he was talking to paul nakasoni
running the national security agency he
was talking to the joint chiefs
so this is a senior military officer
working to de-escalate
a potential crisis and it's it's clear
that these kind of calls between
military leaders can be routine but our
book shows that while calls between such
leaders can be routine certainly this
moment was anything but routine it was a
moment on a back channel to try to avoid
global war to avoid some kind of
miscommunication in the south china sea
or a president who they believed in he
believed was in decline acting out in a
rash way a catastrophic way
and with the nmcc exchange you see him
trying to protect uh the country from
having miscommunication
or an isolated call from the white house
or even the president causing a missile
to be fired or even the nuclear arsenal
to be used
um second question um
talk a bit about bill barr's role in the
final
couple of months um uh
the book
reports instances in which barr
was also
a a a break uh or
or a buffer um
keeping the president from
perhaps doing uh
crazy things
and the question is was was this
about preserving and
restoring or restoring his own
reputation
um
was it about
in some way to protect the institutions
the justice department and uh
and indeed the
proper role of the executive branch um
what would you get
what can you tell us about bill bilbar
how do you sum up a very interesting
personality and certainly he wants to
leave and he left the trump
administration with his reputation
intact with some people not with others
what we found most interesting about
barr
was that he would have private meetings
with trump
and uh in the middle of last year the
election year he went to trump and he
said i traveled the country uh i see
more people out there i see your
supporters and you have incredible
support
there
but mr president i need to tell you
that your supporters think you are an
effing [ __ ]
sorry
i should have made that a-hole uh
well
it is what it is bob bob bob woodward
said the real word we were on the
colbert show the other night and i go oh
boy
here we go
but yeah i mean
it's stunning and and um barr is trying
to give him political advice you think
you are an effing political genius but
you're not
and
barr is a conservative republican and
wants trump to win and when he sees
the whole administration
kind i mean there really is an epic
collapse of the presidency in this
period november december uh january when
he saw this uh
barr wanted out and he wrote a
resignation letter to trump which is
really a love letter about all the great
things you've done
and hoping he can sneak out without
getting a negative trump tweet and
trump accommodates him and tweets and
says oh bill barr has done a great job
so you know this this is complicated but
if you put it all together
all of these people one way or another
including pence including barr certainly
including
milli including the republican
leadership on the hill
senator mcconnell
the house minority leader mccarthy had
disdain for trump and
they behind the scenes would
say things sometimes to his face
and there is a sense when you connect
the dots here that everyone
glimpsed
his unfitness for office
or
that he
he just was not doing the job
trump once here when i asked what's the
job of the president he said to protect
the people well he did everything but
protect the people and his presidency
was defined by protecting donald trump
and uh that now is
that peril uh continues and as we say in
the book uh
you know maybe there's gonna be a
real massive fight in the republican
party between trump and pence or trump
and somebody else uh for that republican
nomination so we're and
you know that
anyone gene you know this better than
anyone anyone who tries to predict the
outcome or where
american politics is going
uh is uh wasting their time because
there is no telling anything
can happen
yeah nobody knows anything especially
now but you you know you talk about
protecting the people
but you know the other day i was driving
down constitution avenue and i looked
over at the washington monument and
those nearly 700 000 little white flags
that are planted all in rows
on the monument grounds each flag
symbolizing someone who died from covet
19 and um and you
you you try to square that with
um the duty um
to protect the american people and um uh
and uh and it's just so tragic um
another question from our audience can
you address the role
of the trump children and jared kushner
do it during
those perilous final days
it's it's based on our reporting it's
not
uh
the the president's children
in particular ivanka trump uh were close
to the president throughout his
presidency ivanka trump was an actual
advisor in the white house uh her
husband jared kushner the president's
son-in-law a senior advisor as well
there is a scene in the book where
ivanka trump goes in to the oval office
a few times three times actually on
january 6 uh at the encouragement of
general keith kellogg and others working
with president trump and tells her
father to calm it down to let it go she
says let it go
but we're careful in our reporting to
not lean into anything we're just
telling you what we've confirmed has
happened we're not making a conclusion
about whether this even mattered to
president trump because there's another
scene in the book that's
i think as a reporter more revealing
that
hope hicks his longtime advisor a few
days after the election says to him
essentially what ivanka trump says weeks
later on january 6 let it go let it go
just let this defeat go go back to
mar-a-lago enjoy political winter run
the gop from the outside in some kind of
informal way and he brushes off ho picks
and says i can never
concede my people don't want me to quit
and
based on our reporting the conversation
was pretty similar on january 6 with his
daughter ivanka jared kushner working on
middle eastern issues throughout the
transition
his children along with others around
the president
many of the president's critics call
them enablers
it's true they're at they at times seem
to be enabling his behavior but
oftentimes they're just turning away
and not doing too much to try to corral
them and when you talk to sources
familiar with them it's clear many of
them just feel it's an impossible task
to do anything but just nod and go along
with what's happening inside that white
house
um
thank you bob another audience question
do you think that trump in his heart of
hearts
really believes the election was stolen
from him
um
bob woodward
it's a great question and i wonder how
you tap into trump's heart of hearts
it's he wouldn't talk to us for this
book though last year i interviewed him
for 10 hours uh he was
not happy with the last book
rage about how he failed to protect the
people
from the corona virus when he was given
intelligence warnings and and so forth
so uh
you know what as reporters you
quickly learn you want to describe
events and behavior
and what's sad
what seems to be the motive
but the motive
is something you never get the full
clarity on what is trump up to
and uh can is he rational enough to know
the election was not stolen
don't know but he's
i think he's one of these people who
said
believe certain things and
uh
even if there isn't evidence and talks
himself into
a belief and it is easy to cross that
threshold
of belief to delusion and i think uh if
you gave him
sodium pentathol the truth serum it
i i will say it would take a lot of the
drug
to figure out what he really
you know what what's going on here but
see that's
the the problem and and the peril is
he's and i got to know him very well bob
costa
in 2015 2016 was often the only one on
the trump
campaign plane or it wasn't even a
campaign at that point and
you can
try to get
the facts
about what happened but what
this is all about uh you know maybe
trump secretly has a psychiatrist or
maybe trump will have a psychiatrist
in the latter
years of his life
and
at least he will get clarity on what
happened the point for
people in our business is that we have
to find some way
to be as factual as possible to not get
into the caught in the political storm
and make political judgments
and
try to invite people in
to this wonderful
opportunity to see what really happened
and what really happened
was a
giant surprise to bob costa and myself
and
the
summary is
peril
remains uh gene real quick
um there's one little scene that's so
revealing uh
right after the election president trump
calls up kellyanne conway his longtime
advisor and he says how do we how did we
lose to that guy buy it how did that
happen how did we lose so for a fleeting
moment he's privately acknowledging well
he did lose and he lost abide but in
that same period he's getting call after
call from giuliani and people on the
right
in congress and outside saying it was
stolen it was stolen and in that same
period as he's talking to conway and
others saying gosh i can't believe i
lost
how did we lose to that guy
he starts to then say well maybe it was
stolen it was stolen and that begins the
drumbeat that fuels this entire
transition period
fascinating
um uh see another question um um
basically was the cabinet uh ever
close to
considering
uh the 25th amendment or
some way of
of believing
president trump of his powers
no because the 25th amendment that the
standard is
is the president disabled
and
pence would as vice president would be
the one who would have to lead the
charge on this and
he steadfastly uh refused to do it but i
think
coming out of this experience and
hopefully
there can be
lessons learned one of them is
is the 25th amendment
sufficient
for dealing with the problem
like donald trump and the second issue
is which
some
experts and
knowledgeable people about nuclear
weapons they're saying do we have a
system
that really makes sense do we have
control of nuclear weapons do
could a president
like trump
and i don't think he was going to start
a nuclear war but if we got into some
sort of military action with the chinese
you could see
china or some country using that small
tactical nuclear weapon and all of a
sudden we'd be on this
perilous escalation ladder that would
take us to armageddon so it was it was a
really dangerous period
and
the mechanisms of the 25th amendment the
mechanisms and procedures for control of
nuclear weapons there's a lot of work
and a lot of examination that needs to
be done in
our view from our reporting
um just one uh one last question uh and
it's about president biden um uh a
uh an audience member has asked and and
you you hear um
on
some news channels um about the the
question of whether he's being
protected by his handlers from tough
questions whether he's being somehow um
um uh uh
considered away from um
from
from
you know the the
hurley burley of the of the presidency
um uh and protected uh over protected uh
in that way
um did you get any sense of that uh in
your reporting on the biden sections of
the book
our reporting shows that there are some
around president biden
who
we they call it the wall uh this effect
of trying to keep him
from
from interviews he did not
choose to participate in this book uh he
did not sit for an interview we note
that in the back of the book
but what's interesting in our reporting
about that question
is
president biden's closest friends and
advisors know he has a career of being
candid at times being a little sharp
and so
on the right sometimes you see coverage
of this aspect of the book and the wall
around biden is some kind of way of
cocooning him from tough questions but
when you look at the book in the context
of what we write it there's a whole
section of
president biden really seeming
in the eyes of his advisors and friends
a little prickly at times
too sharp with the tongue and there's a
hope to keep this politician
who has so much political uh popularity
now in his own party who has the power
of the presidency from meandering into a
gaff moment or to a controversy and you
saw early on this administration
powering through the 1.9 trillion rescue
plan dealing with the virus and you saw
a politician in biden president biden
who
largely averted controversies early on
in gaf type moments uh eventually there
have been a couple but they've been
scattered and few uh as the reporting
shows and in part that's his own
discipline and it's not so much a wall
around him providing himself at a
different time in his life in his career
adjusting his own political approach
okay i'm taking one final question
before i invite our host brad graham to
come with final words and and actually
i'm going to answer the question the
question is how was all of this amazing
information obtained and i can answer
that question it's it it was obtained by
reporting um old-fashioned shula
reporting that um bob woodward has done
for all for his whole career and bob
costa has done for his whole career um
and uh and so that's where it
came from this was um this was this is
not
an exercise in thumb sucking uh it is uh
it is reporting and um and i might add
it is uh it is fabulous eye-opening
historic reporting um uh and and it was
a privilege to uh to share this hour
with you uh by lord and you bob costa
congratulations on the book uh and i
hope everybody reads it brad graham back
to you
great moderating gene and
bob woodward and bob costa really an
epic book
about about epic times and and
you do end it on such an ominous note
you know we won't be able to say
we weren't warned if the peril does
later somehow come back and brings us
down
everyone watching thanks for tuning in
a reminder that in the chat column you
can find a link for purchasing copies of
apparel
from all of us here at politics and
prose
stay well
and well-read
here's a look at some of the
best-selling non-fiction books according
to amazon topping the list is the just
published report by the program taking a
look at the issue we thank all of you
who chose to participate we appreciate
your input
joining us now is robert costa he is the
national political reporter for the
washington post also the co-author of
the book peril along with bob woodward
mr costa thanks for coming on the
program
robert costa thanks for coming on the
program
okay um we're expecting bob costa to
join us any minute now to talk about his
book
so to talk about his book peril uh if
you want to ask him questions by the way
you're welcome to do so and here's how
you can do so if you would just want to
start calling it now and lining up your
questions 202
748-8000 one for republicans 202
748-8002
for democrats and 202-748-8003
for independence you can text us
thoughts and questions too at
202-748-8003
let's try it again mr costa uh this is
uh c-span thanks for coming on the
program this morning
now have him talk
we're going to try one more time robert
costa are you there got him i got him in
my ear i got him in my ear i got him in
my ear
joining us on the program right now
robert costa again the co-author apparel
also the national political reporter for
the washington post good morning
good morning great to be with you thanks
for joining us a lot has been put out
about your book but it was a tweet
yesterday mr costa that i'd like to
start with if we could you wrote this in
a tweet saying why reading the whole
story in peril matters adding beyond the
headlines the eastman memo and argument
it wasn't just a pressure point on pence
it was a pressure point on senator mike
lee of utah one of the most influential
legal minds in the gop there was a push
to get his cred his endorsement if you
wouldn't mind let's start with that what
is the eastman memo and why is it
important to the book
throughout our reporting over about a
nine month period bob woodward and i
found out that the story of january 6
was as much about the insurrection that
day
as it was about the days prior in the
intense pressure campaign on vice
president mike pence but not only him
also on senator mike lee of utah and
other republicans and the
the plot essentially was to throw the
election to the house of representatives
and president trump and his allies at
the time wanted to use a conservative
legal argument to make the case to
conservative politicians and one of the
key players in this was a little-known
lawyer named john eastman a former clerk
for supreme court justice clarence
thomas he drafted a six-point plan which
we included in our book peril that shows
that the vice president in his view
could throw out electors on a january on
the january 6th certification
and
block them from being counted so biden
as president-elect would not reach the
270 necessary threshold for electoral
votes it was a roundabout way of
throwing the election to the house and
ultimately throwing the election to
president trump how does mike lee factor
into this
mike lee is very important because
eastman as we document is pressuring
vice president pence and his lawyers on
january 4th but they're also trying to
get buy-in from conservative senators
and mike lee is a very esteemed
legal mind within the republican party
uh democratic critics may not like him
but within the republican party he is
seen as a top legal mind and because of
that the trump white house believed if
the league could somehow sign on to the
eastman memo it would give it a lot of
credibility as they tried to make the
case in congress so on january 2nd we
report for the first time john eastman
gives this memo to senator mike lee it's
circulated from the white house to lee
and it's all about trying to get the
republican party to come around to this
idea that the certification of biden's
victory can be stopped
how did senator mike lee respond to the
memo
it's a fascinating scene for history not
just as a reporter because as we
reported this out woodward and i found
that lee tried to figure out if
eastman's argument had any credibility
and what eastman is saying in this memo
is that
somehow out in the states there are
alternate electors people who want to be
electors for trump not for biden
so lee calls up all these different
state republican leaders and
legislatures he's trying to figure out
are there alternate slates of electors
because if there are maybe the things
should be delayed uh the certification
maybe they should be considered as
alternate electors now there were groups
on social media saying they wanted to be
alternate electors but what lee found on
a legal standpoint there were no
alternate electors there was no such
movement inside state legislatures to
recognize other slates of electors so
this was a dream for some trump allies
out in several states but it was not
happening inside the state legislatures
and that's what matters that's what
mattered to lee as he evaluated the
eastman memo so ultimately he discarded
the eastman memo and he does not sign on
to the president's push
this is again robert costa joining us
he's the co-author of the book apparel
along with bob woodward 202 748-8001 for
republicans democrats 202 748 8 000
independence 202 some parade 8002. mr
costa you also write a little bit about
the relationship in your book between
the former president and the former
speaker of the house paul ryan
particularly over a series of events can
you recount some of those for us
well paul ryan features it i believe in
the second chapter of our book peril and
then and then then he comes back later
and speaker ryan
is an interesting story uh as you tell
the trump story because he is in effect
the leader of the republican party in
congress when president trump is elected
in 2016 he's the speaker of the house so
much power and he has to figure out how
to deal with this new outsider president
and he sees in some ways someone he can
have a transactional bond with like many
republicans saw someone who could help
him enact republican policies but at the
same time he found trump to be odd and
almost hard to connect with on a
personal basis and on a political basis
and what we discovered in our reporting
is that
paul ryan as speaker of the house was
given manuals documents from a doctor a
friend of his a wealthy republican donor
in new york about narcissistic
personality disorder and paul ryan the
speaker of the house studied these
psychiatric manuals and documents and
articles to try to better understand the
president-elect when you stand back and
think about that the speaker of the
house trying to look to psychiatry to
understand the president of the united
states and using narcissistic
personality disorder as a road map to
understanding this president it's
stunning
that this was happening behind the
scenes even as they were working
together to pursue power and policies an
illustrative of that example paul ryan
is on a hike he gets a call from the
president concerning a topic what's that
topic and how does that conversation go
ryan's on vacation with his family in
august of 2017 and this is right after
the white supremacist march in
charlottesville virginia and the
president has made many comments
about the crowds there using phrases
like many sides and both sides this
infuriates ryan who issues a statement
against the president's response and
long story short
trump calls ryan and says you're not
in the bunker with me you're not with me
and uses a flurry of expletives that i
won't share with the wonderful c-span
audience and this is the president
screaming at the speaker of the house
and it's one of the early breaking
points for ryan where he realizes even
if he studies the psychiatric manual he
can only get so far with trump
mr costa we have calls lined up for you
we'll start with daryl in denville new
jersey independent line you're on with
robert costa co-author of peril go ahead
darryl
uh mr costa first i want to thank you
and uh bob woodward for producing this
book
i think this is really needed by the
american people
the question i have is there was a lot
of talk about the cabinet invoking the
25th amendment to remove trump i was
wondering if you had uncovered any uh
evidence that they were close to that
and um and if not what was the
resistance to invoking the 25th
amendment
i'm going to poke you a little bit you
haven't read peril yet you got to pick
up peril because we get into this and in
the book
we have a whole
major important scene or after january 6
speaker of the house nancy pelosi and
leader schumer
in the senate the top democrats in
congress they call up vice president
pence and they're trying to get him to
invoke the 25th amendment they feel the
president is out of control and the 25th
amendment needs to be invoked and when
he's over at his office vice president
pence knows the calls coming in
but the the speaker and the senate
leader are kept waiting for about 20
minutes they don't take they don't get
in to talk to the vice president on the
phone pence won't take the call and why
doesn't he take the call why doesn't he
consider the 25th amendment because
based on our reporting
pence is told by his lawyer greg jacob
and others that the only reason to
invoke the 25th amendment is if the
president is somehow mentally or
physically incapacitated and that that's
the legal rationale in their view this
of course can be argued by many people
but that was the pence legal conclusion
about the 25th amendment and on a
political basis we show that pence even
after january 6 is trying to still stay
in the president's inner circle to stay
in his good graces we see him
trying to work with the president and
jared kushner and this causes a little
bit of friction actually some major
friction in pence's inner circle how
could you somehow be
so cheerful in a way after january 6 and
everything that happened that tells you
a lot about who pence is as a politician
as a person
and the 25th amendment was something
that was definitely dangled to him but
he never snatched it
from compton california eric democrats
lying go ahead
good morning this is an honor to talk
with you mr costa
my question for you this morning i like
to really understand how much did the
republican party participate in this
insurgency what i see is an overall
operation
as i'm more hearing even with the memo
that they always participating in this
concept and i also see these individuals
that were they are the grandchildren
that
that uh when the grandparents didn't get
their way
during the civil war they divided this
country in this kind same concept the
same attitude of extremism that we see
of through the violence
and using religion
uh christianity is not a religion but
they use it in this context to drive
their extremism
thank you
so your point about the insurrection in
the republican party here's what we
found in our book the insurrection on
january 6 is a bloody brutal event
we are all familiar with the images i
don't need to detail them but the new
york times editorial uh board this
weekend on sunday wrote about our book
and referenced it in their main
editorial and they talked about how the
days before january 6
were a bloodless political and legal war
that it was a major war going on behind
the scenes and that's what our book
shows is that the republican party and
different players who have power maybe
they're in office maybe they're not saw
january 6 as a reckoning and it was not
some kind of sporadic moment that led to
a rally moving down pennsylvania avenue
and then climbing the steps of the
capitol it was the culmination of a
pressure campaign and this is really
shown through
characters like rudy giuliani and steve
bannon unelected republicans who are
very close to president trump who are at
the willard hotel in washington on
january 5th
talking to the president talking through
january 6 as a day to really force
republicans to do what president trump
wants they're talking to president trump
in late december early january all the
way up into the insurrection and so you
see that it's not just about chief of
staff meadows and leader mcconnell and
and leader mccarthy in the house that's
the surface level of the republican
party those with official titles but the
president himself trump was coordinating
with many people to try to make the
sixth a major moment and the scene that
always sticks with me in peril is on
january 5th
near midnight the president opens the
door to the mob he hears the mob out in
the streets in pennsylvania avenue and
he says listen to them they have courage
they have courage and he turns to his
aides in a freezing oval office because
he has the door open and he says what
can we do to get the lawmakers to do
what we want what else can we do at this
moment and one of the people in that
room at that time is dan scavino the
president's social media director he was
recently given a subpoena and in the
subpoena from the january 6 committee
our book is cited and that scene is
cited and what we're trying to do is
fill in the gaps of what was happening
before the six because we all knew the
president was watching the the
insurrection the riot uh
in his west wing dining room his oval
office dining room on the afternoon of
january 6 but the the night of january
5th january 4th eastman and pence in the
oval office with trump these also
mattered to understand the full story
have you given the select committee
access to your notes or is it just the
book itself that they are referencing uh
we they have our book and they're using
our book for their subpoenas
uh and just the book not notes any
background information anything like
that uh we have not shared any of our
material i mean what you have to
understand about this book is that we
spent nine months working to the
absolute end of the deadline this book
was written very quickly for a book
and everything we could confirm
everything that we could confirm we put
in this book
and it's in as vivid detail as possible
dates documents it's all there so
there's not like we it's not like we
left things on the cutting room floor uh
to that end mr this mr costa this is jim
off of our twitter feed saying how would
you know about that conversation between
paul ryan and president trump on that
phone call asking you to explain how you
came to know it
well if you look at the back of peril
bob woodward and i have a note to
readers
and this is a it's a good question and
we try to be as clear as possible about
how we pursued our reporting and it's
important for reporters to do that our
book was written on what's called deep
background
which means we have long interviews with
people familiar with events directly
involved with events sometimes in the
room for events it all depends we don't
discuss who we we talk to for the book
but we do these interviews on deep
background
and we collect all the information and
we use all the information
we are able to confirm we just don't
discuss
where we learned it from and this is to
protect people as they provide documents
to us evidence of of different
conversations notes
emails transcripts of phone calls
to protect that process and them sharing
that information we don't attribute it
but we talk to as many people as
possible to really build our reporting
and that's called deep background and my
colleague bob woodward has worked
and written terrific books for decades
to really get to what he calls the most
obtainable version of the truth and
that's what we want in deep background
has been helpful at times to really get
to that most obtainable version of the
truth uh to that end mr casa was the
joint chiefs of staff uh chairman mark
milley last week testifying on capitol
hill uh about an instance that he that
you recall in your book and he recalls
differently before we go to him explain
what happened in the opening pages of
your book concerning a conversation that
uh general milly had with the house
speaker
well it's important to read the book
because the book shows that chairman
millie on october 30th of 2020 in
january 8th of 2021
has a conversation with the head of the
people's liberation army general lee
and
in both instances
millie within his procedures as chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff
was trying to de-escalate a situation
where he
worried that the chinese based on u.s
intelligence the chinese
could think the us was about to attack
them so the us
and millie specifically
wanted to move the chinese away from the
idea or the suggestion that the u.s
could have
a wag the dog type attack on china and
as our book notes
president trump did not want war with
china millie knew that and we have that
in our book the whole point was about
getting away from miscommunication
because as history has shown
miscommunication can be can often be the
the seed of war and so millie has these
calls to de-escalate a very tense
situation with a major global superpower
an adversary at the very least
and that we're in a hair trigger
environment with china all the time in
places like the south china sea
so here's that part of that conversation
that general milly had on capitol hill
concerning your book concerning a
conversation with the house speaker and
we'll get your response to it
you said in a phone call with speaker
pelosi
she said
quote republicans are enablers of
president trump's behavior you know he's
crazy he's been crazy for a long time
you replied i agree with you on
everything
that was repeated three times in the
prologue of the book pero that you you
told speaker pelosi you agree with her
on everything
is that an accurate portrayal of your
recounting to bob woodward about those
conversations
not exactly no i think that so in fact i
know what is wrong is accurate trail
wrong in fact i know what i said which
was
madam speaker i am not qualified
to determine the mental health or assess
the mental health of this
speaker that you agreed with her on
everything and what i was referring to
when i said that was i agree that we
need to have the processes and
procedures
uh in place to make sure that we don't
have an accidental illegal or
unauthorized use of nuclear weapons and
i do agree with that and we do have
those procedures
you said you agreed with her according
to bob woodrunner i'm not agreeing
woodward is right or or you're right
i am not agreeing with her assessment of
the president
mr costa how do you explain respond to
that exchange
well first of all uh bob woodward and i
stand by our reporting we obtained a
transcript of that call but number two
general milly was under oath and he's
explaining as it's evident i don't even
need to explain it's evident he's given
context for what he said and he said if
he was agreeing with her
as we show in our reporting it was about
the larger conversation that was his
argument to congress he said that under
oath if he was agreeing with the speaker
in the course of that conversation
we just saw the clip
he's saying he's agreeing with her that
things need to be done to protect the
u.s nuclear arsenal and again if you
read the book you see him agreeing with
her on that point many times now we have
in her book that he's also
at least in responding to her crazy
point saying what he said but only he
can know as the person who said it uh
the meaning and context for what he was
trying to say at the time so i'm not
going to get into his head or any uh
person's head
about what they feel or thought or how
they explain something but i will just
conclude by saying we stand by our
reporting nick in
delray beach florida republican online
you're on with robert costa good morning
good morning uh you know listen to this
guy i am cracking up hysterical i didn't
know c-span had a comedy show but it's
funny to listen to him talk about deep
backgrounds and all the rest of this
spy uh speak stuff
this is just another book just like the
russia hoax that this guy pushed for
four years couldn't prove anything and
people like this criticized donald trump
for being unfit for office yet when
donald trump killed an iranian terrorist
this guy went crazy and wanted to bring
him up on war crime charges but when joe
biden kills seven children and a family
this guy remains silent and last point
if donald trump is so unfit for office
how is it that we didn't have any
terrorist attacks we had no afghan
debacle we had no uh illegal alien
invasion at our border and no one
apologized for the china virus and to
listen to this guy talk about the
people's liberation army of china why
doesn't this guy have some guts and call
them what they are they're the chinese
communists
okay thanks nick mr costa you can
respond
uh the gentleman used the phrase this
guy
about four times in each instance
uh that though those statements he made
attributing my own actions are not
backed up by fact but i would just say
in response to the gentleman
uh as a member of the press the fourth
estate i always welcome feedback i
appreciate your comments uh gates north
carolina that's where larry is on our
independent line hello
hello good morning thank you so much for
taking my call and uh my scenario is the
same as the gentleman that previously
spoke
number one
please stop calling it an insurrection
it was a riot
a riot just like in the summer all the
riots that happened
okay
now number two i will never read your
book
because woodward and you
are against
anything that is republican
based
number three
if
you would look into the beginning of
trump's presidency
before he was even sworn in
what the democrats did to him
and just putting
him down all the time and not giving him
an opportunity
is unfortunate
because in the last
number of years
he tried to do things for the american
people okay thanks larry
well larry
i didn't hear a question there uh but
it's interesting to hear your statement
thank you uh part of your book also
deals with the incoming biden
administration
you did a lot of reporting on that as
you said uh as it's coming in and
compared to what it's facing now and
dealing with issues on capitol hill and
other issues how would you assess these
first months of the biden administration
particularly what you wrote about
leading up to it
him coming into office
well it's such an important part of our
book the biden story you can't
understand the end of the trump
presidency without understanding the
beginning of the biden presidency and
how does this person who had run in for
office in 1988 for for the presidency in
88 and 2008 decided to run for a third
time
in 2020 and as we show it was a winding
decision sparked by charlottesville in
2017.
he has to overcome
some challenges
on the family front many challenges on
the political front he ultimately wins
the nomination he builds a
bond with a former foe and senator
bernie sanders and another in senator
elizabeth warren and you see biden
during the campaign saying i'm going to
get ready if i win to have a progressive
agenda and the joe biden i knew when he
was vice president uh would come up to
capitol hill in 2011 and 2012 to cut
deals on fiscal issues with leader
mcconnell he was seen as the amtrak
riding centrist from delaware at obama's
side uh but that biden we saw working
with president obama he's still there
but he's also someone who really wants
to have a progressive legacy and we show
in the book him looking up at the
portrait of franklin delano roosevelt in
the oval office and really telling
senators he wants to go big and we show
that with the 1.9 trillion dollar rescue
plan earlier in the year and to your
question we really see it now
this is a biden presidency at least for
the moment that's aiming to spend
trillions of dollars to establish a new
safety net infrastructure spending uh
coveted relief they're going big
government they're going big spending
and they believe they're
they're not just here to cut deals with
republicans in fact the whole experience
of january 6 seems to have based on our
reporting burned a lot of democrats and
they're not necessarily uh eager to
start cutting major deals with the gop
and and looking at the recent events
with the bible administration how
different is this how different is the
democratic party now for when biden was
a member in congress
well i mean it's so different in some
respects because
issues like medicare for all which were
once on the political fringe have now
been elevated to the the center of the
democratic party
and
you see biden contending as president
with forces in the house like the house
progressive caucus uh that are really
pushing him in a leftward direction but
that said this is not a democratic party
that has changed wholesale
in the 2016 and 2020 elections you still
have
really critical centrists or at least
more moderate centrist senators in the
senate like senator manchin of west
virginia senator cinema of arizona who
are tempering the impulses on the
progressive side in the house so you
have biden in the center
with a foot in each camp and one side of
his political persona and presidency
wants to be in lockstep with the
progressives to go big for history for
the moment now
uh to really do something big ahead of
2022 but you have the history of biden
as someone who was in the senate
oftentimes more with that mansion cinema
spirit of democratic centrism
uh this is with the last call garland
from luftwan texas democrats line we're
running short on time so go ahead with
your question or comment
yeah my comment uh pedro is uh i think
uh what hillary clinton said about trump
back in the day about him uh and the
people that follow him are deplorable
his mother said that uh he was gonna be
chaotic if he ever got in office and
robert costa and
bob woodward i believe everything and i
hadn't read the book but i can pretty
much uh
say that acosta is a good uh reporter
and woodward is and uh donald trump they
he's kjk number and that's how he was
trying to do that insurrection and uh
the people that's uh following behind uh
all this uh still
the the the steal
they deplorable and uh
okay
garland we'll have to leave it there
garland in texas mr costa then
as far as this project is concerned
we've talked a lot a lot of topics but
before we let you go what other things
should people look in the book that we
haven't talked about or maybe you
haven't talked about at length and
talking about the book
bob woodward and i really wanted to work
to provide a portrait of this moment in
america so if you in the final few
seconds here read the whole book to
understand
what happened on january 8th 2021 two
days after january 6 with chairman
millie and others was such an explosive
moment but how we got there biden's
decision to run the campaign
the biden's transition period when he
has to contend with the virus a major
part of the book uh when they when he
comes in the rescue plan ultimately
makes a major decision on afghanistan
our book broke new ground in the
reporting there so the trump material is
so compelling it's very active right now
with the january 6th
committee in the house but this is the
biden presidency and if you want to
learn more about the presidency and the
president right now pick up a copy the
book is peril it's co-authored by robert
costa and bob woodward robert costa also
serving as the national political
reporter for the washington post and mr
costa thanks for your time today thank
you
coming up the supreme court starts its
new term today and we'll talk about not
only what faces the court but major
cases before it the heritage
foundation's john malcolm and the
constitutional accountability center's
elizabeth wydra for that conversation up
next later on on the program we'll be
joined by politico healthcare reporter
david lim talking about covet testing in
the united states those conversations
coming up on washington journal
[Music]